[Musique]
Philippe Doublasi, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Je m'appelle Philippe Dostasi. Je suis
né le 1er janvier 1953
à Lourde
et je suis en avant tout si je me
définis un médecin. Voilà, je suis
médecin, je mourrais médecin, docteur
comme on dit. Et c'est ceux dont je suis
au fond. Euh je suis fait de ça. Je
j'adore écouter les gens, j'adore les
accompagner, j'adore les traiter. Euh je
n'y arrive pas toujours. Mais euh donc
voilà, en fait c'est ça mon métier.
Alors après euh la vie euh vous fait
évoluer. Euh vous finissez par tourner
en rond dans un coin alors vous avez
envie de faire autre chose. Donc ce qui
m'a amené en fait curieusement à la
politique parce que je n'avais jamais
fait de politique de ma vie. Je suis
provincial.
J'habitais pendant très longtemps
Toulouse. J'étais professeur de médecine
à Toulouse.
Professeur en en quoi ? Qu'est-ce que
dans la discipline de santé publique,
épidémiologie
mais sur le plan clinique, je suis
cardiologue et donc à l'hôpital j'étais
cardiologue, voilà. et à l'université
euh santé publique
euh parce que c'est les deux, on est
PUPH, praticien hospitalier, professeur
des universités.
Euh
et alors voilà, la vie fait que à un
moment donné ça marchait plutôt bien
d'ailleurs et j'ai eu l'extrême chance
d'être euh mon père était médecin
et donc dans ce milieulà je reconnais
avoir été aidé
culturellement. J'ai envie de dire pas
du tout évidemment, j'ai j'ai réussi mes
examens mais je dire culturellement. Et
donc, j'ai eu l'extrême chance de
pouvoir partir à un moment donné au
Canada, à Montréal, passé 2 ans
quand j'avais 20
24 ans, quelque chose comme ça. 23 ans
24 ans, 25 ans. Et là, j'ai été
formé par un homme qui m'a extrêmement
marqué qui s'appelle Jean d'Avignon, qui
est toujours en DAignon, c'est un nom
vraiment canadien, québécois. euh qui
est probablement un des plus grands euh
spécialistes des hyperliépidémie,
cholestérol, triglycérides et cetera.
en clinique. Donc c'est il avait
pratiquement la plus grande euh série
d'hyperlipidémie, d'hypercholestérolémie
familiale.
Comme vous savez, il y a beaucoup de
consanguinité euh au Québec et donc euh
en raison de la catastrophe où les
anglophones ont fait presque un génocide
à un moment donné vis-à-vis des
francophones et donc tout le monde s'est
reconstruit entre cousins. Euh et il y a
eu dans un premier temps, c'est plus
vrai maintenant, mais dans un premier
temps, il y a eu des familles de 10, 12,
15, 16 personnes avec des cousins et des
cousines. Et donc à un moment donné, il
y avait sur le plan génétique des
anomalies et en particulier sur le
cholestérol. Et c'est comme ça que Jean
d'Avignon qui avait la plus grande série
de malades qui avaient des
hypercholestérolémies familiales a donné
des sérums à Brown et Gorstein qui ont
eu le prix Nobel de médecine euh en 1984
des gens des Américains de Dallas avec
du sérum qu'on leur a envoyé euh du
Québec. Bon bref, ça a été la chance de
ma vie. parce que euh pour la première
fois de ma vie euh je me suis retrouvé
euh dans une équipe euh mondialement euh
connue et reconnue, faisant des articles
dans les plus grands journaux
internationaux. Vous
publié sur quoi ? Je un jour Journal of
Clinical Investigation, ça a été la ma
ma légende d'honneur euh sur la peau
protéine E. D'ailleurs, c'est
intéressant parce que la peau protéine E
et ça on pouvait pas le savoir euh est
devenue extrêmement importante
maintenant dans l'Alzheimer. Bon mais on
le savait pas. Bon bref et donc j'ai
travaillé là-dessus. Mais pourquoi je
dis ça ? Parce que quand je suis rentré
en France à Toulouse, j'ai monté la même
consultation sur les
hypercholestérolémies, les
hypertriglycérémies. J'ai été
pratiquement le premier. Il y avait un
grand professeur à Paris à Pitié
Salpérière qui s'appelait Gill de Gen.
Euh et en fait moi ensuite brutalement à
je sais pas 27 28 ans, j'ai eu l'extrême
chance de devenir un spécialiste mais
vraiment un spécialiste euh connu et
respecté dans ce domaine là. Donc j'ai
publié sur ça les hypercholestérolum
parce que le cholestérol, les
triglycérides c'est très bête, c'est
c'est des graisses.
Alors on on rentrera dans les détails
des graisses un peu plus tard.
Euh
oui, je peux en parler 2 he on a le
temps. Euh
vous avez été ministre de la santé,
ministre de la culture, ministre des
affaires étrangères euh sous sous l'air
Chirak. Euh Chirak qui vous manque ?
Chirak, il aurait fait quoi s'il était
toujours en vie, toujours président ?
Comment il aurait géré le Covid ?
Mais pardon, juste avant, je vous
explique pourquoi j'avais quand même
divagué sur ça. C'est parce que au fond,
j'étais pas fait pour la politique au
départ. Enfin, je ne pensais pas la
politique,
c'est le médecin ou le politique qui
nous parle ?
Non, mais c'est les deux parce que au
bout d'un moment, c'est un homme est
fait de de de plusieurs choses. Mais je
veux dire par là que donc, j'ai eu
l'extrême chance d'aller au Canada,
extrême chance de pouvoir monter cette
spécialité qui n'existait pas et donc
j'ai été agrégé assez rapidement et j'ai
tourné. Et au bout d'un moment, je me
suis aperçu que au fond ma vie c'était
que pour avoir de l'argent, des
subventions publiques pour faire marcher
mon équipe, pour faire des publications
et je finissais par aller un peu partout
dans les congrès et je j'étais en train
de me dire "Mais ma vie, toute ma vie,
j'avais 33 ans, j'avais 35 ans, ça va
être que ça." Et je je je peur en fait
de la répétition de ma vie. J'ai eu peur
de tourner toujours en rond dans le même
truc et d'autant plus que mon père
faisait ça. Donc j'ai voulu autrement
dit peut-être avoir du coup le nom,
c'était celui de mon père, j'ai voulu
avoir un prénom et donc je suis je suis
allé faire une campagne électorale à
Lourde où j'étais né mais j'avais vécu
15 jours ou 3 semaines parce que je suis
né peut-être je pas avec 10 jours
d'avance et ma mère qui est de là-bas on
a accouché là-bas mais en fait j'ai
toujours vécu à Toulouse et donc à l'âge
de 35 ans 36 ans, j'ai eu envie de faire
de la politique mais je ne me voyais pas
à l'époque on faisait des grandes
affiches 4 par 3. Je me voyais pas sur
les affiches de sur les murs de Toulouse
avec tous mes copains qui allaient se
de moi. Donc je suis allé à
Lourde et à Lourde j'ai fait une
campagne et j'ai gagné et je suis rentré
dans la vie politique comme ça. Voilà.
Euh
sur quelle place sur les chiquit droite
gauche à l'époque ? Alors c'était s moi
j'ai toujours été européen donc je je
suis rentré vraiment sur cette idée là
au fond d'Europe je suis enfin le mot
fédération est tellement qui fait peur à
tout le monde mais c'est pas ça
d'Europe pendant
Oui mais en fait en réalité voyez moi je
crois beaucoup à l'Europe je je crois
beaucoup à cette belle idée on en
parlera donc et donc j'étais qu'on
appelait le parti centriste CDS Mitteran
disait qu'il y avait pas de centrist
était tous à droite mais en fait oui
j'étais centre droit au fond
Euh et donc j'ai été député européen en
le même la même année où j'ai été maire
de de Lourde, j'étais très gâté au fond
parce que 89 maire de Lourde député
européen.
Suement c'est c'est on est bon.
Vous avez été ministre de la santé
Chiraak sous Chiraak. Si Chirak était
encore vivant, Chirak il aurait fait
quoi ?
Alors j'ai été ministre de la santé
grâce à une femme d'abord.
et et sans elle, il y a il y a pas enfin
d'oblait il fait rien sur le plan de la
politique nationale, il n'existe pas
cette femme, je lui dois tout de A à Z,
c'est Simon Vein. Voilà. Donc c'est une
histoire
très intéressante d'ailleurs pour moi et
importante, c'est que je suis euh en
1992 donc et député européen et sur la
liste de Simon Bale d'ailleurs et maire
de Lourde, mais elle me connaissait même
pas. Enfin, j'étais sur sa liste mais
enfin c'est c'est c'est c'est des
différences tellement énormes. Je dirais
elle elle voyait à peu près physiquement
qui j'étais, mais je n'avais pas de
discussion avec elle. Et et en fait euh
moi j'ai été très marqué par le fait
qu'il puisse y avoir une purification
ethnique euh en Bosniers Zigovine. Et
donc un jour, je décide d'aider une ONG
euh et on part une fois, deux fois,
trois fois, quatre fois, cin fois
Sarayevo dans le quartier martyrne de la
farine, des médicaments et là-bas, ça
snipait sérieusement. C'est c'était
extrêmement dangereux et euh et et j'ai
fait ça plusieurs fois. Et un jour euh
Simon Veale était avec des amis en
vacances à août 92 et elle on lui dit
qu'une équipe fait ça et elle dit "Moi,
Antoine, c'était son mari, tu fais ce
que tu veux, moi j'y vais." Et elle
prend l'avion d'un de ses connaissances
et elle arrive à Split. Et nous partions
toujours de split en Croatie pour
descendre ensuite et pour essayer de
tenter d'arriver là-bas. Et on lui
explique ce qu'on fait. Elle dit "Toi,
tu fais ce que tu veux Antoine, moi je
vais avec eux." Je dis "Non mais il faut
pas faire ça parce que c'est extrêmement
enfin c'est extrêmement dangereux. En
tout cas, moi je vois pas là-dedans.
Enfin bon." Et elle y va, elle se met
dans semi-remorque et on part. et ça
dure 8 9 jours, 10 jours et on narrive
pas à ça rayez-vous parce qu'on y arrive
pas parce que c'est extrêmement
dangereux. On passe beaucoup de
checkpoint, c'est très dangereux. À un
moment donné, on voit d'ailleurs un jour
on voit des une sorte de camp quand
même. Alors ça n'a rien à voir avec des
camps bien évidemment de la deuxième
guerre mondiale, mais enfin quand même
c'était c'était des femmes qui étaient
maigres. Je me souviens très très bien
de ça. Et le soir dans une sorte de
campement, le mari de Simon Veine m'a
dit "Là ça fait beaucoup quand même et
on aimerait rentrer." Et j'avais une 105
à l'époque parce qu'on était toujours,
il y avait des semi-remorques mais des
voitures aussi très légères au cas où on
était pris dans un dans un échauffé.
Je suis rentré avec elle, avec lui, on
était 5 dans la voiture et on est rentré
et on a j'ai fait de de jours et de
nuits. On a mis de l'essence dans les
dans la dans la malle de la voiture et
on parti on est arrivé à Split et je me
souviens très bien tout le monde dormait
dans la voiture sauf elle. C'est un de
conservation absolument incroyable. Elle
me disait "Vous voulez un chocolat un
peu 3h du matin ?" Je dis mais d'où vous
sortez ça ? Donc cette femme était
exceptionnelle et nous sommes connus à
ce moment-là qui était des moments
difficiles pour nous et lorsqu'elle est
devenue en 93 au fond quelques mois
après, moi je me je me présentais à
Lourde au à la députation pour la
première fois de ma vie, j'ai pas le
temps de siéger à l'Assemblée nationale
qu'elle m'appelle et elle dit "Mais moi,
on me donne le poste de ministre d'État
des affaires sociales, de la santé de la
ville. Est-ce que vous voulez venir
ministre de la santé
C'est une plaisanterie. C'est
me dit non, moi je vous connais euh on a
vécu ensemble quand même une 10 jours.
Vous allez venir avec moi et moi j'ai
besoin de médias de la santé. Donc
voilà, elle m'a tout appris. J'ai fait,
j'étais pas à l'aise au début parce que
je connaissais pas du tout ce métier.
J'ai pris des engueulades. Euh elle m'a
elle m'a elle m'a appris euh tout ça et
elle me manque. Alors par contre s'il y
a bien une personne de la vie politique
qui me manque, c'est elle parce que
souvent je j'allais la voir, elle me
donnait des conseils, elle m'a toujours
donné des conseils. Elle m'a souvent dit
que je faisais des erreurs parfois
parfois des plutôt ça d'ailleurs parce
que c'est pas quelqu'un qui c'était
quelqu'un d'extrêmement euh direct
et elle avait beaucoup d'affection je
crois. Nous avions de l'affection et moi
beaucoup de respect pour elle. Voilà.
Donc alors maintenant Chirac oui. Shirac
qu'est-ce qu'il aurait fait ? Ben Chirac
c'est pour moi un homme politique
important parce qu'il m'a fait
confiance. C'est pas ma génération. il
m'a fait confiance à plusieurs reprises
et ça ça se pas quelqu'un qui vous fait
confiance, c'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui
vous met dans un gouvernement.
Euh
pour moi, c'est deux personnes. C'est à
la fois un homme politique national
et en même temps c'est un caractère
extrêmement trempé, plutôt militaire
d'ailleurs dans l'esprit,
très extrêmement organisé, presque le
contraire de ce que les gens pensent au
fond.
extrêmement distant, vous voyant ses
meilleurs amis et tutoyant tout le
monde. À la limite, c'était pas une très
bonne nouvelle qu'il me tutoie parce que
je savais que Jupé Touton et cetera il
les vousvoyait
et c'est pour moi quelqu'un
d'extrêmement
remarquable sur le plan de la politique
internationale.
Donc sur le plan de la politique
nationale, c'est pour ça que je réponds
comme ça à votre question parce que
justement sur le plan national, je pense
quelqu'un qui a tenu tout à fait son
rang mais qui faisait extrêmement
attention au peuple français qui savait
qu'il était difficile ce peuple, il
avait pas peur mais enfin il faisait
très attention au phénomène de rue, aux
manifestations. En fait, c'est quelque
chose qui et c'est pour ça qu'il y a pas
mal de gens qui ont dit définitive, il
n'a pas fait les réformes euh
extrêmement mais il savait aussi que le
peuple ne pouvait peut-être pas quand je
dis moi le peuple c'est extrêmement
positif hein, c'est pas c'est pas
péjoratif que le peuple français euh
n'allait pas peut-être les accepter.
Certains lui ont reproché durement en
disant bah en définitive oui, il a pas
fait les réformes qu'il fallait.
Euh par contre, alors j'aimerais bien
parler avec celui qui me dit qu'il a
fait une erreur sur le pont de la
politique internationale parce qu'il se
trouve que euh j'ai j'ai c'était sa
passion au fond. Bien sûr, c'était les
arts asiatiques, enfin tout ce qu'on
connaît de lui. Mais en politique, je
crois que je n'ai jamais rencontré de ma
vie. Pourtant, j'ai rencontré pas mal de
chefs d'état. J'ai eu l'extrême chance
de rencontrer pas mal de chefs d'état et
de parler avec eux. J'ai j'ai rarement
vu cette vision et surtout cette vision
de politique internationale de Chirak
basée sur une chose, pas sur deux, sur
une, sur le respect de l'autre.
Et et c'est ça qui est extrêmement
intéressant dans un moment où tout le
monde s'engueule plus ou moins parce que
tout le monde regarde en fait au fond sa
petite vie. Alors si on est si on n'est
pas occidental, c'est que on est débile
quoi. Enfin je en gros c'est dire que et
tout le monde essaie de vivre toujours
dans son au fond les gens veulent se se
se rassurer. L'histoire de l'homme c'est
qu'il veut se rassurer.
la famille la
religion non
et y compris mais non mais moi je suis
croyant mais je pense que
vous avez un un ami imaginaire vous vous
vous pensez qu'il y a une une super
puissance
non pas du tout je pense que non je suis
je suis croyant je veux dire je suis
catholique mais je je respecte
énormément j'ai beaucoup d'amis athés je
suis pas un grand pratiquant
ce que je veux dire c'est que y compris
dans la religion il y a une partie là
c'est le médecin qui parle Il y a une
partie, je pense de réassurance. On
essaie de se rassurer. D'ailleurs, les
communautés sur internet, ça fait partie
euh aussi on est entre nous. Euh je dis
je dis pas que je suis contre parce que
moi aussi je fais partie de communauté.
Je veux dire, on est tous partis de
communauté mais on se rassure. Voilà.
Donc euh Shirak était au contraire
extrêmement ouvert
et donc euh pour lui, j'ai j'ai une en
mémoire euh quelque chose
d'extraordinaire. C'est euh j'ai eu
l'honneur de le servir comme ministre
d'affaires étrangères et il
combien combien de temps ?
2 ans. Euh mais c'était lui le patron.
Enfin, je dirais moi je je voilà je
autant en médecine si vous voulez je
sens bien que j'ai j'ai j'étais
extrêmement à l'aise au fond euh dans ce
poste autant aux affaires étrangères et
les gens le sentaient d'ailleurs parce
que on en parlait enfin
Chirac était le patron donc voilà il y
avait pas il y avait un conseiller
diplomatique il décidait les choses j'en
parlais avec lui mais enfin c'était lui
le patron acheté minis affaires sociales
Ma réforme de 2004, je l'ai faite. Il
m'a dit "Tu es bien bravo." Mais je l'ai
faite. Là, si vous voulez, d'ailleurs
tous les présidents sont comme ça.
Si vous voulez les deux grands
10 ministres d'affaires étrangères, on
dit toujours Vedrine Jupé, mais au fond
ces deux personnes
Drian aussi, non ?
Comment le Drian ?
Non, le Driant le Drillant a plutôt à
mon avis pour les Français un très grand
ministre de la défense mais c'est un
très bon ministre. C'est un signal de
faire passer un ministre de la défense
au ministère des affaires étrangères ?
C'est un signal au monde ou pas du tout
?
En tout cas, c'est mieux que le
contraire. Mais mais ce que je veux
dire, non mais ce que je voulais dire
c'est que quand vous êtes pas en
cohabitation,
le ministre des affaires étrangères peut
dire "Je pense comme le président mais
quand même je pense que là brutalement
votre niveau s'élève quand vous êtes
couchner avec Sarkozy ou aujourd'hui le
Drillon avec Macron ou
le ministre des affaires étrangères
avec Hollande, mais en définitive, vous
apercevez que c'est le président de la
République, hein.
Il était de la défense au Holland
Leillon. Le le Drillon était à la
défense mais il avait un minise affaire
étrangère. Donc je je dis que
dès que vous n'êtes pas en cohabitation,
c'est le président de la République qui
est vraiment qui donne le la.
Il aurait fait quoi ? Il aurait donné
quel la pour le coronavirus chque Donc
et donc ce que je veux dire par là,
c'est que je termine quand même sur ma
dernière vision de Chirak quand il a dit
au revoir à l'Afrique et il va il va
dire au revoir aux Africains en fond
parce que c'est son dernier voyage, je
sais plus si c'est janvier,
février ou mars 2007 et on va à au Mali
à Bam. Oui, à Bamo. Et et là, il y a des
dizaines de milliers de gens qui
l'attendent
avec des t-shirts et cetera.
Mais ils étaient au fond. Nous, on était
sur le tarmac. On sort
et là on entend au fond, on a la forêt
des sortes de tambour
et des gens qui bougent un peu mais et
c'était ces amis d'ogon d'ogon
tribu qui venaient lui dire au revoir et
petit à petit ils avançaient à leur pas
dans des danses.
Il m'a pris par la main, je me suis fait
par le bras comme ça. dit viens avec moi
et hors protocole
il est sorti on a fait peut-être je sais
pas 200 m 300 m 400 m sur c'est long un
président de la République français qui
arrive hors protocole et qui va vers la
forêt et là ils sortent de la forêt ils
sont à 100 m 150 m et il y a un au
revoir à un des leur et Chirac se
retourne et je vois une énorme larme. Il
tu vois Philippe, ça c'est l'Afrique. Je
veux dire que il y a une connaissance,
vous voyez, il avait une connaissance,
une une un respect pour ces gens.
Et lorsqu'il a fait le Kebran qui est un
succès aujourd'hui, le musée du Québéli
au fond,
qu'est-ce qu'il a voulu dire ? Il a
voulu dire "Je laisse ça parce que comme
il disait souvent, nous on était encore
dans les arbres pendant que ces gens-là
faisaient de l'art.
Kbranli, il a quand même désossé
beaucoup de musées pour faire le
Kbranli. Non.
Ah non, alors ça c'est un vrai débat.
C'est c'est vous mais mais moi je je
pense parce que Stéphane Martin est
quelqu'un auquel je tiens beaucoup et et
et qui a été aussi un homme très
important pour moi dans ma vie
professionnelle parce qu'il était
directeur de cabinet au ministre de la
culture, c'est un grand président. Moi
je crois beaucoup que le musée de
Kébronl est très important, très
important qu'il soit à Paris. C'est un
très beau musée d'ailleurs.
H
très beau musée et il y a une très bonne
immersion à l'intérieur. Il est très
bien conçu. Euh bon façon
enfin je vous ennuie avec tout ça
peut-être mais bon
non non on a pas l'habitude des des
préliminaires aussi long dans les
présentations. Mais c'est très agréable.
On a le temps donc on peut on peut se
permettre de prendre le temps. Euh vous
m'avez pas répondu. Shirak il aurait
géré comment le coronavirus ? ilait
géré, vous savez en fait Chirac, je
pense qu'il l'aurait géré plus peut-être
davantage, on va dire de manière euh
parce qu'en fait c'est le ministère de
la santé qui l'a géré cette fois-ci au
fond de A à Z et moi je connais bien le
ministère de la santé.
C'est le Covid-19 de ce de de c'est le
ministère de la santé
qui a géré.
Il a pas été aidé par le qued d'ors il a
pas été aidé par les services de
renseignement. Il a Tiens, une question,
j'en profite avant de vous relancer pour
un un moment. Le ministre de la santé
euh vous avez été ministre de la santé
deux fois, vous avez été ministre des
affaires étrangères. Est-ce que ce type
de ministère
a un accès direct à des renseignements
extérieurs de qualité made in France
avec des gens sur place pour nous tenir
au courant ? Est-ce que le ministre de
la santé était à votre avis en 2019
connecté avec les services de
renseignement pour savoir ce qui se
passait ? Non. Le qui est d'ors
peut-être ?
Oui, bien sûr.
Ah d'accord.
Mais mais je vais vous dire pas là que
c'est c'est ça que je voulais dire,
c'est que en fait je crois que Chirac
euh
mais moi j'ai du respect hein pour le
président actuel, j'ai du respect pour
la fonction et j'ai du respect pour pour
l'homme qu'il est. J'ai j'ai du profond
respectement
et surtout dans le second tour de
l'élection présidentielle qui a eu je
veux dire j'ai voter les deux mains les
deux fois pour lui. Donc ce soit clair.
Bon mais ce que je dis c'est que à un
moment donné de crise aigue
euh il est important que l'Élysée,
la défense et l'intérieur soit dans la
boucle. C'est c'est dans une crise crise
importante. Voilà, un peu comme le
Covid-19.
Comme le Covid-19, oui,
parce que justement il y a un problème
d'organisation
et allons-y directement. Prenons prenons
l'exemple. Euh nous sommes un des pays
au monde à avoir le plus enfin parmi on
va dire les les quatre ou cinq dans le
monde à avoir le plus de machines PCR.
Polymerase Chin reaction. C'est la
fameuse PCR qui qui
pour les analyses
pour les anon c'est ça c'est PCR pour
pour faire le virus pour pour avoir le
diagnostic virologique après les
covillons
qui les a les CHU les centres
hospitaliers public euh les labos privés
gros labbaux privés parce que
aujourd'hui il y a de très gros labbaux
privés qui font 60 % quand même des
analyses biomédicales en France
et puis vous avez toutes les unités
incermes de l'Institut national de la
santé de la recherche médical les CNRS,
l'INRIA et vous avez les véaux. Bon, au
passage pour être véu, il faut être
beaucoup plus intelligent que pour être
médecin en France.
Le concours,
vous savez pourquoi ?
Je ne sais pas pourquoi.
Un animal, ça ne parle pas.
Ça c'est votre explication mais mais bon
voilà. Donc en fait
curieusement le ministère de la santé a
décidé que il y avait je sais pas x
machine PCR qui était tamponné ministère
de la santé référencé point elles
peuvent tester et c'est tout les autres
non
et pourtant il y a des patrons de je
vous assurer que les scientifiques Inms
enfin l'INCERMS c'est une magnifique
maison quoi. Je veux dire, c'est c'est
eu la chance d'être rang B euh classe B
de Incerm et même dans les commission
qui permettait d'évaluer les autres
quand j'étais chef de clinique je peux
vous dire l'incerme ça marche. Voilà
donc l'incerme les gens étaient plutôt
confinés le laboratoire ne marchaient
pas mais enfin les PCR elles marchaient
et donc on aurait pu très bien leur
demander d'autant plus qu' ils étaient
demandeurs. On l'a pas fait
surtout on était en guerre
qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on
est en guerre ? Non mais d'où
l'intérieur la défense c'estd que à un
moment donné vous avez des vous avez des
gens dans c'est le métier ça de gérer
une crise. C'est ça existe dire
dans le corps.
Non non mais je veux dire ça existe.
Ils ont un peu foiré. Non
non mais là au ministère de la santé ça
n'existe pas. au ministère de la santé,
vous avez des des agents régionaux de
santé euh qui sont des directeurs d'ARS
qui sont des gens très bien par
ailleurs, mais c'est pas leur métier,
c'est pas la la stratégie militaire,
l'organisation militaire, c'est pas leur
métier. Ce sont des gens qui ont par
ailleurs des remarquables qualités. Le
ministère des affaires sociales, c'est
des gens vraiment de qualité. Moi je les
connais, je veux dire c'est des gens
formidables. S'ils ont choisi d'ailleurs
le ministère des affaires sociales de la
santé, c'est pas pour rien. C'est c'est
ils auraient pu briller à Bercer ou ou
ministère de la culture justement. Non,
un sacerdoce choisi.
Oui. Non, c'est c'est vraiment des
qualité et Simon Val me l'avait appris
d'ailleurs ça. Il m'a dit "Vous savez
les gens ici, il faut les respecter
parce que
il pourrait gagner 10 fois plus
ailleurs.
Ah ! Et puis surtout, il pourrait aller
dans des dans des ministères qui
brillent un peu plus et qui ont
d'ailleurs des primes parce qu'à Ber, je
vous signale qu'ils ont des primes qui
n'ont rien à voir avec ce des affaires
sociales. Donc moi, je respecte
l'administration des affaires sociales,
de la santé. Donc ce soit clair, précis
et net. Mais dans une crise comme
celle-là, on a besoin à un moment donné
d'avoir des gens qui organisent, des
généraux, des chefs d'étatmajor. Vo
pas laisser Jérôme Salomon seul euh tout
faire de A à Z sur de la France. Je veux
dire, c'est enfin Jérôme Salomon ou un
autre, enfin c'est le directeur général
de la santé. Donc j'ai trouvé, je pense
que Chirac pour répondre à votre
question, je pense que il y aurait eu
des conseils de défense, on va dire euh
presque presque tous les deux jours ou
en tout cas on aurait on aurait organisé
il y aurait eu un monsieur qui aurait
qui aurait été en charge de ça. Test,
est-ce qu'il y en a suffisamment ?
Masque, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
il y aurait eu alors que tout est
remonté dans un ministère qui était pas
prêt à ça.
Minè de la défense là,
le ministère de la santé n'était pas
prêt à gérer une la stratégie sanitaire
a été un peu dépassée. Ils ont été très
très très bons au fond. Agence publique
France a été très bon au début parce que
quand mine monois c'est quoi ? un
cluster, ils y vont, ils trouvent que
c'est le médecin anglais, il remontent
les contacts, ils vont voir des enfants,
ils vont dans les écoles des enfants,
ils trouvent tout, ils font les cas
contact, c'est remarquable. C'estàd que
c'est un des pays au monde qui a le
mieux géré ça au début.
Et quand il y a eu Mulouse en effet et
d'autres d'ailleurs en particulier dans
des lieux de culte ailleurs que à Mulous
là le système n'a pas fonctionné.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'il n'y a pas eu de
test.
Qu'est-ce qu'a fait Raou ? C'est pour ça
Ra
non non mais c'est Non mais qu'est-ce
qu' a fait ? Ne parlons pas de Je parle
pas d'hydroxychloroquine. C'est ça qui
est intéressant. Qu'a fait Raou ? Parce
que c'est le seul qui a fait ça. Donc
c'est intéressant.
Lui, il a téléphoné au véau à l'INCERM
CNRS à tous ces gens-là, je sais pas à
qui mais enfin tous les gens qui avaient
des machines PCR. Il leur a dit "Venez
tester, on teste beaucoup." Donc il a
testé 6 % ou 7 % de la population
marseillaise. Tous les gens qui avaient
mal à la tête des courbatures et cetera
sont passés en disant "Moi, je veux
savoir si j'ai le Covid ou pas." Dès
l'instant où le PCR était positif, hop
quarantaine. Mais si vous mettez en
quarantaine tous les gens à Paris euh
qui ont eu le Covid plutôt que de les
laisser chez eux en Île-de-France ou
dans le Grand Est, vous n'avez pas le
taux de mortalité que vous avez
aujourd'hui. Vous comprenez ? Donc c'est
extrêmement important le test pour
répondre à vos questions sur Chiraak.
C'était en fait une organisation
militaire qu'il fallait mettre en place
de gestion de l'État au plus haut niveau
pour tester la population symptomatique.
Ça
pas été fait.
Mais c'est ça la question. Alors j'ai
pas de test.
Un jour, j'ai eu un coup de téléphone de
monsieur euh
Fabrice Lom. Euh donc un homme
politique, un appel de Fabrice Lom qui
est un journaler d'investigation pour
ceux qui nous écoutent. Euh on se dit
qu'est-ce
ils ont fait un bouquin sur euh les
quartiers. Non
en tout cas je sais pas pourquoi il
m'appelé et donc moi je me demandais ce
qui se passait et en fait ils me disent
nous avons exumé un dossier qu'on a
trouvé que vous avez écrit en 2004.
Vous avez fait une conférence de presse
en 2004.
Ils en ont fait la une du monde il y a 3
semaines
ou un mois, enfin nous je crois 3
semaines euh en disant "Ben, vous avez
écrit tout, qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Il
y a une pandémie virale ?" Et en effet,
j'avais dit au président Chirak, il y a
un truc qui me plaît pas là-dedans. Je
suis plutôt je je suis de je suis un
enseignant en épidémiologie en santé
publique. Euh je pense que il y a
beaucoup de choses à faire dans
l'hôpital, il y a beaucoup de choses à
faire pour les médecins. Mais il y a un
truc où on n'est pas bon, c'est que si
un jour on se prend parce que c'était
quand même 2004, moi quand j'arrive au
en tant que patron des affaires
sociales,
là où était Simon Vein en 93. Bon et
bien euh je je je me dis le SRAS c'était
en 2003
euh Dieu merci le feu s'est éteint.
Mais si on si on prend un virus virulent
dans les avions à partir de je sais pas
où dans le monde, ça va arriver partout.
Et s'il est très virulent, c'est une
catastrophe.
Et euh Shirg me dit "Mais est-ce qu'on
est prêt ?" Je dis non, on n'est pas
prêt. Il vas-y. Donc nous avons fait en
un texte que je pourrais vous passer qui
est disponible. J'ai fait une conférence
de presse, personne n'est venu ou
presque. En gros, c'est de dire de c
blad veut se faire encore mousser quoi
en gros. Et personne ne s'y intéresse.
Je vais à la commission des affaires
sociales de la de l'Assemblée nationale.
Bon, quelques députés qui m'écoutent
gentiment. Bon, très bien, merci. Et ça
s'arrête là. Ensuite, moi je pars aux
affaires étrangères. Xavier Bertrand me
succède à la santé. Il continue à faire
ce travail, il le fait très
sérieusement. Et en 2007, donc quand
Chirak s'en va, il y a je crois que
enfin, il faut lire le monde, mais enfin
c'est 1 milliard 2 ou 1 milliard 5 de
masques. Euh et et tout est prêt. Donc
ça veut dire moi j'avais écrit si le
virus arrive par là, on contrôle les
frontières. Sinon, on les ferme, il y a
plus d'avion. Ensuite, on va
immédiatement
réquisitionner les
euh industries textiles pour faire des
masques. Ben, tout est écrit si vous
voulez. Les rassemblements ont terminé.
Voilà. et ça et alors en plus après il
crée l'prus qui était un établissement
public justement destiné à gérer les
stocks de masque à gérer justement la
crise
avec quel budget
avec un budget le budget de l'État donné
à l'pruch je ne sais pas combien il
était parce que j'étais plus ministre à
ce moment-là et vous avez
malheureusement vous avez un article que
vous pouvez reprendre qui qui est triste
d'ailleurs parce c'est le dernier
article qu'il aura écrit par celui que
je considérais comme le meilleur
économiste de santé en France qui
s'appelait Claude Le Pen et qui a écrit
un texte dans le monde il y a 3 mois,
vous le verrez 4 mois, il est mort 15
jours après et qui a parlé de l'épus qui
a dit "Mais comment se fait-il que on
ait pu démanteler tout ce qui avait été
prévu en France pour préparer une voilà
et donc c'était je pense que Chirak
enfin ça vous répond ça répond à votre
question c'est que Shirac était quand
même un militaire dans
D'accord. Quand vous étiez au ministère
des affaires étrangères, vous aviez des
contacts avec les services de
renseignement bien entendu.
Oui.
Est-ce que les services de renseignement
sont censé faire remonter des menaces
qui pourraient toucher la France ?
Bien sûr.
Quand l'ambassadeur Billy fait remonter
le 31 décembre que il y a un virus
dangereux qui court dans la ville de
Wan.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe dans ces cas-là
au ministère des affaires étrangères ?
En tout cas, je ne sais pas du tout ce
qui s'est passé. Imaginez-vous, vous
êtes encore ministre. Qu'est-ce qui se
passe ?
Si si je l'apprends en tout cas,
euh j'en informe au fond le président en
premier.
Sous combien de temps ?
Immédiatement.
J'informe son conseiller diplomatique
euh parce que j'ai appris que en étant
minffaires étrangères que on pouvit il
fallait à tout prix passer par le
conseiller diplomatique. Bon mais
c'est quoi le conseiller diplomatique ?
C'est la garde prétorienne de Macron.
C'est quoi ?
C'est un homme qui ou une femme
il est élu ? Il est il est
non pas du tout. qui est choisi, qui est
un ambassadeur au fond et qui est choisi
par le président de la République pour
être à côté de lui. C'est lui qui au
fond le voit le plus en permanence et
qui décide avec lui. C'est des gens de
très grande qualité quand même en
général.
Enfin voilà, donc c'est lui qui lui
ensuite informe le le président. Je je
pense si vous voulez que là, il faudra
refaire le film parce que je ne le
connais pas euh bien. Ce que je sais
c'est qu'il y avait encore des avions
qui arrivaient de Ouran assez tard au
fond dans notre pays. Alors après,
pourquoi on a été touché beaucoup et
l'Italie aussi, nous sommes quand même
des pays touristiques.
Si vous regardez d'ailleurs bien la
densité de propagation du virus, là où
le virus se propage le plus, je veux
dire,
c'est plutôt les endroits des grands
aéroports.
Il y avait combien de correspond il y
avait combien de vols direct Charles de
Gaulan
en 2019 ? Est-ce que Charles de Gaulle
était réputé déjà à votre époque pour
être l'aéroport le plus connecté euh à
Non, moi à mon époque pas du tout mais
euh c'était mon époque c'était
malheureusement longtemps, c'était en
2005 2006 donc mais là il y avait un
ouran Paris direct tous les jours.
Tous les jours.
Euh donc
tout le monde savait que Charles de
Gaulle était un des aéroports
occidentaux potentiellement les plus
contaminés de part ses correspondances
directes avec la Chine. Mais oui, mais
là moi je vais vous dire, on a vraiment
et je veux vraiment jouer la carte de
complètement de l'honnêteté avec vous et
cetera, mais simplement je ne veux pas,
vous voyez rentrer dans moi j'aurais
fait mieux parce que je ne suis pas sûr.
Non mais je vous le dis franchement, je
ne suis pas sûr que j'aurais fait mieux.
Je ne sais pas là. En tout cas, ça a pas
fonctionné. C'est très intéressant
d'avoir les déclarations d'un d'un
ancien ministre de la santé ou de de des
affaires étrangères qui nous dit "Moi,
si j'apprends le 31 décembre qu'il y a
un virus dangereux, je préviens tout de
suite mon président
ou
parce que j'ai été prévenu par les
services de renseignement ou par le
corps diplomatique ainsi de suite."
C'est très intéressant à comprendre.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez que de
déclarations d'Agnèse Buisin sur le fait
que elle a déjà prévenu que ça a été une
catastrophe, que les élections c'était
n'importe quoi, qu'elle y allit avec une
boule au ventre ? Là, il y a quel qui le
sait et le président
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas comment je
ne sais pas c'est moi ça passe en tout
cas moi alors je vais vous dire ce que
je pense. Je pense que
on va se mettre des vitamines là.
D'accord.
Moi je regarde je regarde je regarde
quand même à de près même si j'ai vécu
longtemps
on en parlera j'espère de mon passage
aux Nations- Unies. J'ai vécu longuement
à l'extérieur
de la France mais enfin je regarde quand
même ce que font les ministres de la
santé. ça m'intéresse. Euh et je dois
vous dire que
le passage de madame Busin au ministère
de la santé au début euh j'ai pensé
qu'elle était très bon enfin qu'elle
qu'elle elle avait été présidente de
l'INCA de l'Institut national du cancer.
C'est une bonne professionnelle.
En tout cas, j'estimais que elle avait
tout à fait sa place là. Ce qu'elle a
fait sur la vaccination. Alors, on peut
évidemment beaucoup parler de la
vaccination, mais en tout cas, elle ce
qu'elle a fait, elle a voulu le faire,
elle l'a fait, elle l'a fait avec assez
de courage d'ailleurs et elle l'a fait.
En tout cas, je n'ai jamais alors après
la loi évidemment hospitalière, ma santé
2022, ce sont des lois hospitalières.
Donc c'est pas pour réformer le système
de santé en général. Mais enfin,
d'ailleurs, elle était assez côtée par
les Français. En fait, c'était quelqu'un
qui était considéré voilà
quand elle nous a annoncé les
affichettes sanitaires à Charles de
Gaulle, tout de suite elle est tombée de
son pied des stal là.
C'est ça
hein.
C'est ça. Et là là, c'est
c'est quoi ça ? C'est c'est quand quand
on met à Charles de Gaul le hub le plus
contaminé d'Europe, on met juste des
petites affichettes. Même en Mauritanie,
ils avaient des températures des des
thermomètres dès qu'il passait la que
n'importe qui passait la frontière.
Alors que vous avez expliqué en 2004 que
si on était
potentiellement exposé à une pandémie,
il fallait fermer les frontières,
bloquer les avions ainsi de suite. C'est
c'est quoi ? C'est une c'est une
décision bien sûr politique de préserver
jusqu'au dernier moment une économie au
détriment de la santé. C'est quoi ?
Non. Alors, vous avez plusieurs éléments
qui jouent, hein, c'est que en fait
quand même, il y a eu beaucoup de
départs de feu. C'est-à-dire que il y a
eu beaucoup de fois où on a dit,
souvenez-vous l'histoire de Bassel, de
madame Basselot
où on lui avait reproché d'en faire trop
pour pas beaucoup. Bon, donc il y a eu
beaucoup de départs de feu et donc euh
évidemment euh il y a beaucoup de gens
qui disaient euh "Non mais ça va
s'arrêter, c'est purement chinois." Euh
euh elle-même d'ailleurs, elle l'a dit,
elle dit "Mais ça c'est chinois euh dire
on est à l'abri." Pourquoi ? Parce que
c'était déjà arrivé.
Vous
parlez de busin, c'est ça ?
Oui. Je veux dire que dit voilà, il y a
très peu de chance que la pandémie
territoire ça. Elle a dit ça là quand on
le voit maintenant.
très très bien informé. Non
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
il y a beaucoup de gens au ministère qui
devaient dire ne faites pas de souci ça
va faire comme d'habitude c'est les
Chinois qui vont en prendre un peu puis
ça va s'arrêter c'est un virus qui va
s'arrêter. Bon, il y a eu des gens qui
ont dû dire ça, d'autres ont dû dire
"Mais attention à l'économie,
si vous arrêtez euh les il faut quand
même se rendre compte de la puissance
économique est devenue la Chine."
Donc, je veux dire les pressions que
vous avez le jour où vous arrêtez euh
des avions de Chine en face, vous avez
quand même quelques questions qui sont
qui vous sont posées quand même
diplomatiquement.
Du genre
bah du genre pourquoi vous arrêtez nos
avions ? Euh c'est un incident
diplomatique.
Euh à quoi pensez-vous ? Je ne dis je ne
sais pas encore une fois je je parle de
ce que je ne connais pas là. Mais
est-ce que l'ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères pense que la Chine a
menti ?
Ah, je pense que la Chine a menti
pendant 3 semaines.
À quel niveau ? À partir de quand ?
À partir du mois d'octobre, à partir du
mi-octobre, elle a commencé à mir.
Non, je dis que non, moi je dis que
c'est plutôt novembre.
Novembre. Début novembre ou mi-novvembre
? mi-novembre au moment où vraiment on
sent que on voit bien quand même que
rétrospectivement les cas sont en train
de de se multiplier
et ensuite toute la partie justement
décembre. Ça c'est extrêmement
important.
Est-ce qu'elle a menti sur le nombre de
décès ?
Je ne le sais pas.
Est-ce que vous avez une intuition ?
Aucune.
Une fulgurance ?
Je n'en ai jamais eu
du tout. Donc malheureusement euh
du courage, vous en avez eu
du courage ?
Oui. H
ça serait trop présomptueux de dire que
du courage, mais il faut demander à mes
amis si j'en ai ou pas. Mais euh
est-ce que vous pensez que la Chine a
menti sur le nombre de morts ?
Tout le monde pense que moi je ne dirai
pas ça comme ça tant que je ne suis pas
sûr. J'ai pris l'habitude de vraiment
dire ce que je savais. Moi j'ai j'ai
voilà j'ai je pas inventé. Voilà je
m'est arrivé dans la vie.
dans le joli des choses et cetera. Tout
ça c'est derrière derrière moi.
On va encore s'imaginer que vous êtes
mon ministre des affaires étrangères.
Dans ces cas-là, vous faites quoi ? Vous
appelez nos nos James Bond nationaux qui
sont déployés. Vous vous leur dites
"Écoutez les gars, j'ai besoin de savoir
si les crématoriums brûlent un nombre de
corps ahurissant. Est-ce que vous avez
moyens de me déployer des yeux et des
oreilles là-bas ? Est-ce que le le le
ministre des affaires étrangères peut
passer un coup de fil en disant nous
sommes sourd, nous sommes aveugles et
nous sommes cjat et manchaud ? Nous
avons besoin de nous d'informations
propres clair et nette.
Non, il y a eu de la part de la Chine un
blackout, c'estàd que il d'accord que la
Chine fait un blackout mais nous est-ce
qu'on a des capacités de de d'aller voir
?
Non mais si personne ne vous dit qu'il y
a une épidémie, vous êtes pas plus
intelligent que d'autres. Vous savez pas
qu'il y a une épidémie. Nous on n'a pas
de service de renseignement. Par contre,
on a une communauté en Chine qui dès le
15 janvier
Ah oui nous en
15 janvier. Ah non mais c'est pas vrai.
15 janvier. Ah
non mais le 15 janvier oui. Mais 15
janvier le président le président le
président le président était censé être
prévenu depuis le 31 janvier. Non le 31
décembre.
Je ne sais pas mais enfin en tout cas le
15 novembre je pense que les autorités
de Wouran ne disent rien ni à notre cons
en novembre.
Je parle de novembre.
Oui mais en janvier.
Non mais en janvier tout le monde le
sait. En janvier, tout le monde sait
qu'il y a il y a il y a il y a que il y
a que l'OMS pour dire que c'est pas une
maladie à retombée internationale. Je
veux dire le moi je fais France info le
24 janvier à 8h30 du matin. Euh enfin
c'est samedi, je sais plus c'est le 23
24 ou 25 je crois que c'est le 24 et et
là c'est à 8h30 du matin. Et donc
quelqu'un me pose la question comme en
plus j'ai voulu me présenter à direction
générale de l'OMS et je me suis fait
battre séchement. euh parce que j'étais
pas le bon candidat probablement mais
enfin donc
je sais de quoi je parle quand je parle
de l'OMS et donc et donc je dis mais
pourquoi l'OMS je suis la première
personne en France qui dit pourquoi
l'OMS ne dit pas c'est le niveau 1
maladie à retombée internationale car au
moment où je le dis le 25 janvier ou 24
janvier samedi il y a déjà
je sais pas h pays touchés voire 10 même
L'Australie était touché le 25 janvier.
Donc c'est vous dire que là il y a un
problème, c'est que donc l'OMS on sait
pourquoi mais avant
confiance à l'OMS.
Alors l'OMS
on peut pas parler de l'OMS comme ça. Si
vous voulez que je parle de l'OMS, je
peux en parler. Voilà. Mais donc voilà
et donc et donc là oui je enfin je vous
me posiez une question sur le mensonge.
Je pense que les Chinois ont été
étonnants sur plusieurs points
au début sur 3 semaines je dirais
de 15 novembre à 8 décembre 9 décembre
ils n'ont pas dit les choses. Ensuite,
de manière extraordinaire, je dois dire
que les on a vu les progrès fulgurants
que les Chinois ont fait, ils sont
devenus pratiquement les meilleurs
chercheurs au monde, hein. Enfin, je
dire on a eu immédiatement là, il y a eu
aucune aucune cacherie et cachoterie.
Ils ont donné la carte génétique du
virus.
Ils avaient depuis quel mois déjà ?
Je ne sais pas depuis quand il l'avait.
C'est très intéressant de savoir.
Non, mais c'est certainement très
intéressant de savoir.
On fait un pari. Vous vous pensez qu'ils
ont la carte du virus depuis quel mois ?
sais pas, je ne sais pas.
Novembre, octobre,
je non mais je ne le sais pas. Jeobre
je ne le sais pas. Je peux pas vous
dire, je ne le sais pas. Mais par contre
ce que je sais, c'est que on reçoit en
Europe en Europe avant même que les
catastrophes arrivent la carte génétique
du virus. Donc on peut faire Non mais
monsieur Drosden, le virologue de génie
de l'hôpital de la charité à Berlin, lui
il fait il fait tout de suite un test
grâce à ça. Il crée le test, il le met
online et tous les virologues de
d'Allemagne aidés par la
décentralisation des landeurs, font tous
le même test. Et l'Allemagne est testée
et l'Allemagne a quatre fois moins de
mortalité que la France uniquement sur
ça. Là, on parle pas de chloroquine
hein, on parle de test général et
d'épidémiologie parce que qui dit test
dit dépistage, qui dit dépistage dit
quarantaine quatzaines des malades
positifs et on revient à au bémi
ou mais comment vous pouvez être aussi
affirmatif parce que on va dire que les
Allemands génétiquement ils sont
légèrement différents de nous. Ils ont
une alimentation qui est différente. Ils
sont pas sous la même latitude, c'est
pas la même température, ils sont plus
costaud, ils sont ils sont exposé à plus
de virus ou des virus différents.
Comment on peut dire officiellement
voilà bah il y a moins de mort parce
qu'ils ont plus testé ? Moi je peux vous
dire voilà le le le taux de le taux de
de de décès à Marseille et c'est à peu
près le même qu'à Bordeaux. À Marseille,
ils ont testé et à Bordeaux ils ont du
foie gras et du pinard.
Et là je vous réponds que vous n'êtes
pas épidémiologiste et ça se voit. Je
suis pas épidémiologiste mais
je vais vous répondre pourquoi hein ?
Je vais pas me permettre de vous dire
une phrase,
on commencera on commencera l'apéritif
un peu croustillant juste après.
J'aimerais qu'on finisse sur l'aspect.
Non mais je vais pas vous laisser je
vais pas vous laisser dire que
Non non non ça bien sûr mais non je vais
pas vous laisser dire ça ça c'est très
intéressant ce que vous dites parce que
je provoque c'est fait exprès parce que
beaucoup de gens il y a beaucoup de gens
qui disent à juste titre d'ailleurs
enfin arrê enfin à juste titre non ils
croient que c'est à juste titre parce
qu'ils ne sont pas épidémiologistes ils
disent mais attendez arrêtez de nous
ennuyer avec ça il y a eu le virus il
était dans le grand test il était à
Paris mais il n'y a pas il y en a pas à
Toulouse donc c'est normal qu'il y a une
mortalité basse à Toulouse. Il y en
avait pas à Marseille dans qu' une
mortalité basse à Marseille. Donc
arrêtez de nous embêter. Donc la
mortalité à Marseille et à Toulouse
c'est la même parce qu'il y a pas de
virus. Non mais ça c'est des c'est des
blagues. C'est pas c'est comme pas comme
ça qu'on fonctionne.
C'est vrai que la mortalité est basse à
Toulouse parce qu'il n'y avait pas de
virus. Ça c'est vrai. Saucisses.
Par contre par contre ce qui est
important c'est la chose suivante, c'est
que on hospitalise
on hospitalise pour le Covid quelqu'un
toujours pour la même raison. Et donc il
y a une étude qui a été faite.
On reviendra, on reviendra sur
le test Non mais le test est très
important. Voilà.
Oui, bien sûr. Identifier, c'est comme
le
vous me dites pourquoi en Allemagne ?
Parce qu'il y a des sociétés. parce que
à Autriche, ils ont fait le test cin
fois moins.
On en revient on en revient à la
question initiale. La question initiale,
c'est acquisition, interception de
renseignement, donc test. Vous êtes
d'accord avec moi ?
Comment ?
Pour connaître son théâtre d'opération,
il faut faire du renseignement.
Le ministre de la santé, le ministre des
affaires étrangères, ils font du
renseignement. Enfin non, miné de santé,
le ministère de la santé ne fait pas de
renseignement extérieur.
Non, mais par contre, il peut bénéficier
de mes impôts qui sont utilisés pour
faire du renseignement extérieur. Ça
peut servir à ça accessoirement. Vous
avez raison.
Surtout en terme de pandémie, non ?
Surtout quandout,
je pense que les Chinois n'ont rien dit
jusqu'au 15. D'accord. Ma question
initiale c'était vous à votre époque ça
commence à dater j'ai je avec tout le
respect que je vous dois est-ce qu'on
avait des capacités au qu d'ors d'être
d'être moins borgne moins sourd moins
aveugle moins manchaud moins cjat que
les autres ?
Je pense que quand
diplomatie la personne qui est en face
ne parle pas euh vous n'avez pas le
signal. Euh si non mais je vous dis
qu'il y avait pas des morts partout à
Ouran parce que ça se saurait quand
même. Je veux dire
pas des morts partout mais par contre on
voyait les Chinois qui commençaient à
souder des portes dans les quartiers
pauvres. On a eu extrêmement de mal pour
envoyer des gars dans les cartes de
Poul. Donc à partir de ce moment-là, moi
personnellement ce que je pense vu
rétrospectivement,
je pense que il fallait arrêter en effet
les vols en provenance de
fermer les frontières
fermer les frontières de Chine en tout
cas. Mais encore une fois, c'est très
très délicat et très difficile. Vous
avez plein de gens auquet d'ors qui vous
ditent "Mais vous faites vous êtes fous
ou quoi ? Vous fermez pas les frontières
avec la Chine, ça se fait pas comme ça."
Donc c'est extrêmement compliqué.
Souvenez-vous d'Ebola.
Ébola il y a une grande discussion. Euh
Marfant,
hein ?
Marfant aussi. Oui. Non mais c'est très
intéressant parce que à un moment donné,
je sais plus, c'était euh je crois que
c'était un RDC. Quelqu'un a dit "Mais il
faut fermer les frontières des RDC parce
que il y a une infirmière euh de je sais
pas quelle ONG qui était américaine.
Alors, elle est arrivée aux États-Unis.
Les Américains, ils se foutent enfin
pardon, les Américains, c'est pas leur
premier problème, on va dire, quand il y
a des grosses maladies, sauf
lorsqu'elles arrivent chez eux. Alors
là, il commence à faire attention. Donc,
il y avait une infirmière
qui travaille dans une organisation non
gouvernementale qui arrive au Texas ou
je sais pas où. Certainement pas au
Texas. Que les gens qui nous écoutent
regardent où elle arrive. Et là, tout le
monde dit
"Attention, il faut fermer les
frontières." Et là, vous avez toute une
théorie de gens qui disent "Attention,
dans l'OMS et dans beaucoup d'ONG
françaises aussi et d'ONG mondial qui si
vous fermez les frontières, vous avez le
taux de pauvreté.
en Afrique qui explose. Si le taux de
pauvreté explose, vous avez le taux de
gens qui sont traité par des
antirétroviraux
contre le sida qui explose. Vous avez
nombre de gens qui ont du palu, qui ont
plus de d'artémisine et cetera. Donc
aujourd'hui, d'ailleurs, je vous signale
que le la vraie mortalité du coronavirus
en Afrique, c'est les 500000 doses de de
de d'antirétrovirus qui n'arrivent pas
pour le problème du fra en Afrique. Et
ça, ça fait pas une ligne, enfin ou deux
lignes. Euh alors que nous ça n nous on
a euh 45 personnes en réanimation, ça
fait à peu près quatre pages de tous les
journaux français. Donc je le dis au
passage. Donc voilà, c'est extrêmement
important les contrôles des frontières
pour répondre à votre question. Ça se
passe pas comme ça. C'est c'est une
question extrêmement difficile qui est
pas facile. Ceci étant, je reconnais que
l'avion Uran Paris aurait dû être pour
moi arrêté plutôt. Et
et et par exemple les correspondances
Chine, nord de l'Italie, nord de
l'Italie, Paris,
le nord de l'Italie est très intriqué
avec la Chine pour des questions de
business. Euh est-ce qu'il fallait euh
euh penser à une
personne ne s'est rendu compte à ce
moment-là. Je crois que
parce que personne ne connaissait le
business de l'Italie.
Parce que personne ne s'est rendu compte
surtout que parce que vousz avoir la
carte génétique du virus c'est une
chose. Connaître une maladie ça est une
autre. Aujourd'hui, le Covid personne ne
le connaît. Vous avez euh on vient de on
vient de trouver que 70 % des gens qui
avaient le Covid en 60 % ou 70 % des
gens qui ont le Covid ont des problèmes
de de des troubles pulmonaires au
scanner.
70 % des gens touchés
des gens touchés par le quelle forme
quel 60 % de gens qui ont été vu pour
PCR positive ont eu des scanners
qui ont montré des lésions pulmonaires.
Donc je veux dire sans qu'ils aient des
sans qu'ils aient des signes
pulmonaires. Donc donc je veux dire
c'est une maladie je prends cet exemple
mais ça peut être modifié il y aura des
checks pour regarder mais je veux dire
ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est une
maladie qu'on ne connaît pas. Voyez, par
exemple euh pourquoi on dit c'est une
petite grippe au départ on a dit c'est
une petite gripe.
Oui, les gens qui dit que c'est une
petite grippe sont trompés. Quelle était
votre réaction quand quand on a dit
c'est une petite grippe ?
Non, moi j'ai
je n'ai pas été heurté par ceux qui
disent fait euh la grippe fait 20000
morts parfois par an.
Donc ça personne ne le dit et ça ne
s'est jamais écrit et pourtant ça fait
20000 morts. Alors des années où ils
font 10000, parfois elle fait 25000,
parfois elle fait 15000. Bon enfin c'est
de l'ordre de grandeur. Et c'est vrai
qu'au début cela a été dit. Ça ne m'a
pas choqué mais quand quelqu'un a dit
c'est une gripette ça ça m'a choqué.
Qui a dit ça ?
Je sais pas. J'ai lu ça dans la presse.
Enfin je ne sais pas. Ça a été dit.
Enfin c'est vous qui l'avez dit à
l'instant mais c'est voilà ça a été dit.
C'est des choses qu'on a dans la tête.
Ça c'est choquant. Pourquoi ? Parce que
euh ça c'est ça ça ça veut dire que on
sait mais le type qui a dit c'est une
cripette, il sait pas et moi je sais
pas, je je personne ne le savait. Par
contre, on pouvait dire "Écoutez,
nous nous énervons pas trop parce qu'il
y a quand même 20000 morts par grippe
par par an." C'est pas pareil. Voyez, je
veux dire voilà. Donc moi, en tout cas,
je me suis bien gardé de le dire. De
toute façon, comme depuis 10 ans, je ne
fais jamais aucune émission de
télévision, c'est pour ça que ça me
change de vie depuis 2 ans, 2 mois et
demi.
Ils appliquent les mesures barrières
correctement dans les studios télé.
Est-ce qu'ils sont comme nous en vous
êtes absolument parfait que j'ai pas vu
ça.
Je je dis à tous ceux qui nous regardent
parce que je suis le seul sans masque
moi. Mais euh voilà. Donc je
que ils ont des visières, qu'ils ont
tout ce qu'il faut porter de main.
Ouais. et et et donc je je pense que les
gens n'ont pas compris quand même ce
qu'était ce virus et c'est c'est normal
pas ce virus, cette maladie pardon,
Covid-19 euh parce que le le scarf Cov 2
on le connaît mais Covid on le connaît
pas et on n' pas fini. Au début par
exemple, on intubait les malades,
c'était une erreur. Bon au début on ne
mettait pas d'anticoagulant
les gens, ils mouraient dans les
pulmonaire. Donc je veux dire c'est ça a
fonctionné comme ça. C'est c'est la vie
qui est comme ça. C'est pour ça que les
gens qui vous font les grands numéros
là, les gens qui voient plus de malades
depuis longtemps comme moi d'ailleurs.
Mais mais moi je fais pas de leçons à
tout le monde.
Qui qui vous avez en tête quand vous
pensez à ça ?
Non mais vous avez des très grands
professeurs qui sont normal
je suis invité en permanence sur des
chaînes d'information continue donc je
rencontre des gens. Bon voilà euh mais
en même temps j'ai plein d'amis et mon
fils a 26 ans. Donc il a plein d'amis
qui sont internes et qui sont chef de
clinique qui sont au boulot. Donc il
voit ça et et moi il me raconte ce
qu'ils vivent ces gens-là tous les
jours, hein. Donc voilà. Donc on a
façon de faire du renseignement.
Ah oui de toute façon si vous faites de
la politique sans renseignement vous
êtes un très très mauvais homme
politique hein. Donc c'est c'est très
important. Mais c'est le drame du
pouvoir d'ailleurs, c'est que si le
pouvoir vous isole totalement c'était
mon cas d'ailleurs quand j'en faisait un
haut niveau. Donc voilà. Donc je pense
que les gens ne savaient pas ce que
c'était que ce Covid. Ils sont pas
rendus compte avec une vue extérieure
maintenant. Et d'ailleurs, il fallait
reprendre, c'est pas pour dire je je je
mais il fallait reprendre le plan de
2004. Voilà.
Donc on savait pas ce que c'était.
Je vais vous poser une question une
question de de béoien à tout bib de
béoien un peu éclairé mais mais une
question les masques grand publics
en terme d'efficacité pour ralentir la
propagation de quoi que ce soit. Alors
on va rendre ça trivialement. Les
masques grand public, c'est on fait un
masque avec un tissu qui n'est pas testé
pour les microparticules inférieures à
tant de de choses. Euh ça sert à quelque
chose ou c'est la bobologie politique
pour rassurer les gens et faire
redémarrer le le business que les gens
reprennent le métro en étant rassuré et
en croisant les doigts que il y ait pas
trop de contamination. Alors, de ce que
j'ai lu, si le masque de grand public
est fait avec du coton et que la
personne en face de vous a le même, on
va dire, euh c'est de l'ordre de 95 %.
Enfin, c'est
coton. Quel tramage, quel grammage au
mètres carrés, quelle capacité de Enfin,
je crois que c'est quand même
extrêmement efficace lorsque on voit ce
qui se passe à au fond et on s'est
tellement moqué de ces gens, on revient
à Chira qui n'aurait jamais fait ça.
Euh, on se moque de ces gens qui ont des
des masques depuis très longtemps.
Enfin, il y a des gens qui ont pas
confiné quand même et qui se sont
présentés avec des masques en permanence
comme Hong Kong et qui n'ont rien eu qui
sont à côté de la Chine. Bon, ils sont
même dans la Chine. Le masque grand
public fait avec un vieux caleçon.
Ouais,
ça ça peut servir.
D'après ce qu'on m'a dit, il y a du
coton dedans, même si je connais pas le
grammage.
D'accord. Donc les mesures barrières de
distan distanciation physique, ils
appellent ça distanciation sociale mais
distanciation physique,
ça sert à quelque chose ? Ça sert à rien
tel que ça a été présenté par le
gouvernement. Parce que on compare, on
est en train de comparer le le discours
du gouvernement avec les distanciations
sociales, le nombre de mètres que
quelqu'un tousse avec sans masque 600
FFP2 FFP3
et j'en passe. Les Japonais
ils font des simulations
sur la propagation de microparticules,
micro gouttelettes qui restent dans
l'air plus de 10 minutes, 4 minutes
en aérosol. Est-ce que on nous a pas
encore floué en disant lensation 1 m ça
fonctionne, il y a pas de problème ?
Non mais c'est c'est toujours pareil,
c'est pas encore de la bobologie
politique ça.
Non mais c'estàd que 1 m vous avez vu
que parfois c'est un m de parfois c'est
2 m
parfois c'est 4 m chez les Japonais
et parfois c'est 4 m. Ben c'est ce qui
est sûr, c'est que plus vous êtes loin
de quelqu'un, mieux c'est enfin dire
c'est c'est du c'est c'est très bête ce
que je viens de dire mais enfin euh
c'est certainement vrai. C'est dire que
puisque je vous postillonne dessus, bon
ça c'est plutôt mètre et demi. Bon
d'accord,
ça dépend hein. Vous avez pas eu euh
certains mais je me suis pas encore mis
en colère, c'est pour ça. Mais mais mais
en fait au bout d'un moment
on a vu que seul a existé. Donc c'est
pour ça qu'il faut un masque et les
masques, les masques, les masques, c'est
trè très très important. Et
deuxièmement, je pense qu'il y a pas de
la bobologie. Je pense que au début il y
avait rien. Il n'aurait pas dû dire
personne n'aurait dû dire que les
masques ne servaient à rien. Ça c'est
évident. Euh
sant qu'on sait que les masques servent
à quelque chose, non ?
Bien sûr. Oui, les masques servent à
quelque chose.
Non, mais ils servent à rien quand on en
a pas. C'est ça.
Oui. Oui, c'est ça. Oui, ce que je suis
en train de dire. Oui.
Autre question concernant le les les
mesures barrières. Euh quand on on voit
un rassemblement de Schtroumpf à 3500
personnes à Landerna en pleine pandémie
mondiale avec l'OMS qui était déjà en
train de convulser.
C'est bien, c'est pas bien, c'est
raisonnable quand on voit un marathon
avec 15000 jeunes femmes pour courir
ensemble, c'est bien, c'est pas bien ?
Mais moi j'étais contre ça. J'étais
contre surtout la venue de ce match de
foot aussi. C'est
match de foot. Enfin match de foot.
Tous deune région qui n'était pas
contaminée. Il a dit le monsieur.
Ah oui enfin bon enfin ça été ça été ce
n'était pas bien. C'est pareil pour le
premier tour des élections municipales.
Voyez je viens avant avant votre
prochaine question. Je l'aurais je ne
les aurais pas faites personnellement en
tant qu'épidémiologiste.
Voilà.
En tant politique vous l'aurez vous
en tant que c'est ça. Alors c'est ça qui
est trop compliqué. Par contre,
lorsqueen tant que politique euh je sais
pas, j'ai lu euh j'ai lu quelque part
que les euh euh tous les partis
politiques voulaient donc bon c'est très
compliqué. parti qui ont pas été
contactés d'ailleurs.
Non mais voilà, donc je crois que
c'était pas je ne sais pas ce qui s'est
passé mais enfin en tout cas euh moi en
tant que mais je suis quelqu'un m'a
demandé de faire un je suis extrêmement
heureux d'ailleurs, j'ai été très honoré
de faire un une un article pour la revue
des deux mondes qui arrivera
prochainement sur cette sur cette
épisode
et je me suis exprimé là-dessus
justement. Je je je pense que euh la
santé est politique. Moi moi je pense
que là c'est le titre d'ailleurs de mon
d'article. La santé est politique. Donc
je pense que
je pense que Angela Merkel est une
scientifique euh a géré en scientifique
euh les choses. Je pense que à un moment
donné, je crois que ça vous aide d'être
dans ce genre de chose. Toujours pareil.
Enfin, ailleurs, c'est autre chose. Bon,
mais je je pense qu'à un moment donné
euh il faut agir en scientifique, il
faut agir en épidémiologiste et il faut
agir voilà, mais c'est pas les
épidémiologistes sont pas président de
la République, je le saurai. Donc voilà.
Mais mais c'est vrai que
je pense c'était des risques. Oui, bien
sûr, sont des risques. Tout
rassemblement est en risque. Ce qui se
passe en Guyane aujourd'hui, ce qui
s'est passé en Corée du Sud, il y a qui
qui a remarquablement géré cette cette
crise. La Corée du Sud qui avait dépisté
de manière très large et donc a eu très
peu de mortalité. Et bien les jeunes
sont partis
en boîte de nuit. De nuit, boum, il a
fallu refermer tout. Euh ça va très
vite.
Est-ce que vous trouvez qu'on déconfine
un peu trop tôt en France ?
Non, je pense que c'est bien fait. Euh
je pense que le ministre d'éducation
nationale m'impressionne. Je trouve que
euh il a très bien fait. Ça a très bien
marché. C'est pas évident. C'est une
peur des parents, une peur des des
mères, peur des Je trouve qu'il bien
débrouillé. Je connais pas donc je suis
très à l'aise. Mais je trouve que ce ce
ce bonhomme a été sérieux. Euh c'est
très compliqué, on le saura très vite
parce que c'est 11 11 mai, c'est ça ? 11
mai plus 15, ça fait 26 donc on va y
être très vite. Euh je crois quand même
qu'on est sorti de l'affaire. Je crois
je crois. Mais attendons comme je viens
de dire en Iran, c'est pas le cas. Ça ça
flambe. À Singapour, on croyait être en
santé d'affaires, c'est remonté mais
avec des gens qui sont venus de Ouran.
Voilà. Attendons. Mais je crois quand
même que c'est que c'est bien parti.
Euh on va revenir à votre casquette de
ministre des affaires étrangères euh
pour repasser ensuite sur votre
casquette de ministre de la santé. La
Turquie, qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
À quel point de vue ?
Point de vue diplomatique, point de vue
migratoire.
Et puis votre avis de médecin concernant
les flux migratoires avec l'épidémie,
comment ça se passe dans les camps de
migrants ?
Alors d'abord, il faut savoir que vous
préférez dîner avec Erdogan ou dîner
avec Vladimir Poutine ou dîner avec
Emmanuel Macron ?
Macron en premier, Poutine en 2 Erdogan
en 3e.
Ça c'est clair.
Et MBS ?
Mais j'ai eu beaucoup de chance parce
que j'ai déjà dîné avec Poutine.
MBS vous le mettez où dans le top
? Je connais pas. Mais vous vous disez
alors attendez vous pouvez pas poser une
fois à la fois toutes les questions,
mais je peux vous répondre sur Poutine,
je peux vous répondre sur Macron, je
peux vous répondre mais laissez-moi
faire, laissez-moi répondre.
Allez-y.
Donc euh le premier ça a été Erdogan.
Alors ça c'est pour moi important parce
que c'est une période que j'ai bien
connue, c'est 2006 2005
où là il y a un grand papier dans le
monde
signé par Valéri Cardestin
qui dit jamais
jamais jamais au grand jamais la Turquie
et ses 100 millions de musulmans un jour
ne devons rentrer dans l'Union
européenne.
suivi par beaucoup de gens, énormément.
Valérie Giscardestin, c'est celui qui
avait signé des contrats pour les avions
enfleurs. C'est ça
ça ? Je sais pas, je trop petit. Et et
donc non mais je sais pas mais non mais
n'a pas fait que des erreurs et il a
fait des choses. D'ailleurs, si vous
avez voté à 18 ans, c'est grâce à lui.
Bon euh alors non mais ne me coupez pas
dans mes dans mon élan sur cette
affaire.
La question c'était est-ce que oui ou
non la Turquie devait rentrer dans
l'Union européenne ou pas ? Vous aviez
monsieur Gull qui était à l'époque
ministre d'affaires étrangères comme moi
et moi j'étais le ministre d'affaires
étrangèr de Jacques Chirac qui pensait
que lui il fallait mieux que en gros les
Turcs regardent vers l'Union européenne
que vers l'Iran.
C'est un choix. On on peut se dire non.
Voilà. Et à l'époque les sondages en
Turquie
étaient à 65 % ou 60 % en faveur enfin
bon, il faudra checker
dire de bêtis faire attention. Enfin
bon, c'est très positif en fonction de
l'Union européenne
et au moment où
on peut les prendre. Alors, je sais bien
que ça peut poser un problème, je peux
très bien comprendre que 70 millions ou
80 millions de musulmans dans l'Union
européenne peut poser un problème
culturel et cetera, notre notre
héritage, je dire chrétien et cetera.
Mais enfin de l'autre côté, vous avez
quand même de la géopolitique à faire.
Vous avez soit ces gens qui justement
musulmans qui regardent vers l'Union
européenne qui est quand même
aujourd'hui un pays démocratique
euh où la liberté de culte existe,
liberté d'expression existe.
Se tendre he quand même hein,
la liberté publique, la liberté
d'expression.
Non, d'accord. Enfin, je vous souhaite
quand même de vivre enfin de de je vous
souhaite de voyager beaucoup et de
comparer ensuite la liberté d'expression
que vous avez en France en particulier
celle que nous avons entre nous là et et
dans les autres pays du monde parce que
vous aurez beaucoup plus de kilomètres
carrés, vous n'avez pas le droit de
faire ce genre de chos que dans que à
mon conseiller
où on peut pas le faire.
Corée du temps
partout mais partout mais vous pouvez
pas vous imaginer comment c'est fliqué
partout c'est terrible dictatures sont
pas sont énormes nombre de dictatures
qu'il y a on dit pas suffisamment au
français d'ailleurs qui ne voyagent pas
suffisamment pour ne s'en rendre compte
parce que voilà bon mais la question
c'est donc moi je pense qu'il valait
mieux qu'il regarde l'Union européenne
plutôt que vers l'Iran. Bon très bien.
Ensuite, Erdogan est arrivé et Erdogan
est un homme qui est extrêmement
euh qui a qui a qui a quand même
mis ses normes de liberté à la poche
en en Turquie.
MBS, un dîner avec lui, ça vous pose
problème ou pas ?
Alors alors je vais vous dire MBS
c'est ça qui est très intéressant en
politique
c'est qu'on pourrait très bien se dire
comme la plupart des gens MBS il a euh
si on ne connait si on ne connaît pas la
culture au fond
alors c'est quoi la culture saoudienne
c'est ça ne connaît pas la culture
saoudienne.
Vous la connaissez la culture saoudienne
? Non
je je connais pas grandchose.
Est-ce que vous avez eu la chance de
sortir avec une princesse saoudienne ?
Non non malheureusement pas.
Malheureusement pas. Mais mais euh en
fait
soit vous êtes à court terme et vous
dites MBS a divisé en c'était combien de
morceaux ce pauvre ce ce cet homme là ?
Cachogi.
Cachogi. Cachogi.
Alors il y a eu des il y a eu des petits
morceaux hein.
Bon très bien. Donc et il a fait ça
c'est affreux. Très bien. Je suis
d'accord.
Qui dit qui qui vous dit que c'est lui
qui a fait ça ? Non mais non mais je
n'ai pas dit ça. J'ai dit vous dites si
quelqu'un dit
résume à dire il a fait ça ça ne va pas.
Deuxième chose
quelqu'un vous dit oui mais attendez euh
il y a des cinémas qui s'ouvrent. Bon
des cinémas qui s'ouvrent en Arabie
Saoudite. Ah bon ? Je savais pas. Ah
mais les femmes, elles peuvent conduire.
Ah bon ? Les femmes peuvent conduire.
Euh mais j'ai vu des femmes à Riad. s'en
voile. Vous avez vu les femmes sans voil
et bon. Oui, c'est MBS qui veut ça. Bon
ben donc là vous commencez déjà à
changer aussi un petit peu parce que
vous dites bon c'est intéressant. Ah b
faire je trouve que Dubaï c'est trop
petit. il va faire euh des choses, on va
pouvoir boire de l'alcool, pouvoir il va
ouvrir des grands hôtels internationaux,
il va sortir. Donc ça veut ça veut dire
qu'il va diamétralement opposé il est
diamétralement opposé à cette sorte de
rigidité religieuse qui existe aussi en
Arabie Saoudite. Donc donc vous voyez,
c'est compliqué. Moi je ne dis pas oui,
je ne dis pas non, mais je n'aime pas
les caricatures. Donc
la caricature, c'est la caricature OK,
il fait conduire les femmes, donc il
peut couper le morceau les journalistes.
Non non, c'est ça. La caricature, c'est
de dire c'est un type qui est
épouvantable, c'est un type qui est très
bien, c'est un type qui est remarquable,
c'est un type exceptionnel, c'est un
type qui adore. Non, je je n'ai pas je
n'ai pas je ne vais pas vous répondre
comme ça. Moi, je ne suis pas
suffisamment euh je dirais voilà, je
suffisamment au fait et suffisamment euh
voilà, je je ne sais pas répondre à
votre question au fond, mais je me dis
que c'est plus compliqué que ça quoi.
C'est il y a quelque chose cet homme qui
est plus compliqué, c type qui essaie de
faire quelque chose. J'ai peut-être pas
encore tout à fait saisi où il va, c'est
vrai, mais arrêtons de faire les les
raccourcis. Voilà. Si Poutine avait
passé au mixeur un journaliste,
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on aurait
fait ? On aurait expulsé des diplomates,
on aurait fait quoi ?
Non, mais euh Poutine ne fait pas ça
d'abord, mais Poutine,
ça sait pas.
Oui, ça pas. Non, ça d'accord. Ça, on
peut aller très loin comme ça, mais
Poutine, il a fait autre chose. Poutine
a estimé en crimé que il pouvait y
aller, il pouvait Voilà. Donc ensuite et
ensuite vous avez l'Union européenne à
côté qui dit "C'est pas bien."
Oh
bon. Oui.
C'est ça. Voilà. C'est pas bien. Donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe au fond ?
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez faire ? faire
attention parce que nous sommes nous
sommes une génération euh qui n'avons
pas connu euh la guerre.
Non, votre génération n'a pas connu la
guerre. C'est ça.
Oui.
Et surtout et surtout
Non, mais la vot non plus. Non non mais
par contre la nôtre on a bénéficié de
cette transmission intergénérationnelle
grâce à nos grands-parents.
C'estàd la génération de de vous c'est
la génération qui nous fout un peu dans
la merde. Non
enfin je sais pas qui fout la merde qui
Ce que je sais c'est que
ce que je sais c'est qu'on n pas connu
la guerre ni vous ni moi.
Alors on connaît la guerre économique
nous. Mais moi je suis Non non mais la
vraie guerre guerre économique.
Non mais le jour où vous aurez
moi il se trouve comme médecin, je suis
allé de temps en temps voir la guerre la
vraie je vous assure que je on fait la
vite la différence entre la vraie guerre
et la guerre économique et la guerre
avec des armes qui vous tuent
physiquement. Non mais attendez je
termine.
Et et donc là c'est extrêmement
important parce une affaire importante
qu'il faut que qu'il faut comprendre. On
peut s'amuser avec les réseaux sociaux,
on peut traiter tout le monde de tout.
Mais mais il y a un moment où la guerre
le jour où on décide de la faire, c'est
extrêmement une grave. Voilà. Vous
avez fait votre service militaire ?
J'ai fait mon service militaire. J'ai
fait mon service militaire des
conditions. Oui, j'ai fait mon service
militaire. Oui,
c'était les grandes vacances, c'était
quoi ?
Oui, voilà, c'est ça. C'était à
çait la coopération à l'époque. Enfin
bon, je l'ai faite bien sûr.
Vous avez tiré avec une arme ?
Absolument pas. Vous avez pas tiré
pendant votre service militaire ?
Oui, mais je sais pas tirer. Vous me
demandez si je sais tirer avec une arme.
C'est pas pareil. Est-ce que j'ai tiré
Ça m'est arrivé de tirer une arme ? Mais
je ne je ne suis pas je ne je ne pas les
armes et je ne sais pas.
Revenons à nos moutons. La Chine MBS,
quand on vend un laboratoire P4, des
laboratoires P3 à la Chine, on se dit
c'est une coopération, on fait du
business avec eux. Quand on vend un
laboratoire P4 à l'Arabie Saoudite,
est-ce que ça vous pose problème en tant
qu'ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères et en tant que tout bib ?
Un laboratoire P4 euh où ça vous dites
à l'Arabie Saoudite. Vous savez c'est là
où on passe les journalistes au mixeur.
Non, je je je pense que nous devons
faire extrêmement attention.
C'est trop tard. Non, je dis je dis nous
devons faire extrêmement attention,
c'est ma réponse, nous devons faire
extrêmement attention à l'accompagnement
que
seconde par seconde
euh de ce genre de de gestes
diplomatiques qui sont fait sont déjà
des gestes diplomatiques.
C'est extrêmement important parce que
comme vous dites, les guerres seront
plus les guerres avec des armes
peut-être qui sont des armes comme des
fusils, mais ça sera peut-être des
bactéries.
Et donc et donc et donc il faut faire
extrêmement attention
euh euh à ça. C'est c'est c'est
il faut certainement pas jouer avec
facilement
avec ce genre de décision.
Il faut pas trop faire de geste comme
ça.
Non.
Si vous deviez
nous transmettre une image de ce geste,
c'est quoi ? C'est une main tendue ou
c'est un pantalon baissé ?
Non. C'estàd que si vous voulez, il n'y
a qu'une seule chose qui compte dans le
P4, c'est la science.
Le reste ça m'existe. Ça n'existe pas
pour moi.
Après vous faites autre chose. Vous
voulez vendre rafale, vous vendez
rafale. C'est notre notre discussion.
Récteur nucléaire.
Récteur nucléaire. Absolument.
C'est c'est de la science. Non mais
récteur nucléaire c'est autre chose. Une
grosse discussion sur réacteur
nucléaire, on peut l'avoir mais sur P4
c'est scientifique. D'accord ? Voilà.
C'est on ne peut pas sortir de là.
Personne n'a le droit de sortir du
scientifique. On parle de P4. Donc
voilà, c'est ma réponse.
C'est une confiance.
C'est un geste de confiance. Non,
il y a pas de confiance dedans. Il doit
y avoir une une
évaluation permanente et un
accompagnement, on va dire.
Est-ce que ça a été le cas pour la Chine
?
Ben, je pense que ça l'a été. Absolument
puisque ça l'a été puisqu'il y a eu et
d'ailleurs les Américains l'ont dit, il
y a eu un accompagnement permanent au
point que les Américains ont dit que les
conditions de sécurité n'étaient plus
réunies.
On a entendu beaucoup de théories
souvent farfelu sur le fait que le virus
aurait potentiellement pu s'échapper
d'un laboratoire
made inine France
en Chine parce que c'est un laboratoire
médine France non ?
Alors
est-ce que est-ce que on parle il y a
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites ?
Alors votre avis
éclairez-nous. Non moi non je n'ai pas
d'avis sur ce qui s'est passé. Je pense
que c'est une coronavirus. Il y a
tellement eu de coronavirus qui sont
partis. Il y en a quatre. Les quatre
premiers, c'est des grippes. Ça donne
des rhumes, pardon, c'est pas des
grippes, ça n'a rien à voir avec le
virus de la grippe, excusez-moi. C'est
ça donne des rhumes, ça donne
l'équivalent de ce que pourrait donner
une grippe, mais ça donne des rumes, on
le voit même passer.
C'est une des conditions d'ailleurs,
mais une des raisons pour lesquelles
certaines personnes sont beaucoup moins
touchées que d'autres. Enfin bon,
c'est qu'il y a des immunités croisées.
Oui, c'est ça. C'est pas impossible.
C'est c'est en tout cas c'est il y a des
tous les cor
il y a des gens qui travaillent làdessus
tous les coronavirus tous les cas de
coronavirus qu'on a vu passer en France
ces dernières années qui ont été passés
dans les chiffres de la grippe parce
qu'en général c'est ce que je dis ça
c'est exactement ça.
Ils font ça les tibent voilà bon ça
c'est un coronavirus hop ça va dans le
chiffre de la grippe on est d'accord
mais oui je pense. Oui. Et
et euh et l'immunité croisée ça peut
aider.
Non il y a des gens qui travaillent
dessus. J'ai dit voilà ce que j'ai
entendu. Alors ensuite vous en avez un
qui s'appelle le Strasce. Bon, on
s'aperçoit quand même qu'il y a une
mortalité importante. Euh et ensuite, il
y en a un autre qui s'appelle le MERS
qui est midaliste respiratory syndrome.
Et c'est pour ça quand on me dit que la
chaleur va faire disparaître, faire
attention quand même. Et là, lui est en
Arabie Saoudite aux Émirats un peu. Bon
voilà,
la maladie du chameau. C'est ça.
C'est ça. Et puis vous avez celui-là
donc si vous voulez bon alors alors
ensuite vous avez l'institut pasteur. On
n pas grand on a pas beaucoup de choses
exceptionnelles en France mais enfin il
y en a quand même une que tout le monde
nous envie dans le monde c'est quand
même l'institut pasteur concoyote.
Oui. Lastit pasteur. Donc l'itut pasteur
est
remarquable et est tout à fait formel.
Alors, c'est pas la question que m'avez
posé parce qu'il y a des gens qui ont
dit "Mais attention, l'homme aurait pu
créer euh ce virus." Vous n'avez pas dit
ça, mais ça c'est impossible parce que
on connaît les ancêtres de ce virus.
C'est un virus qui a une tante, une une
grand-mère et ça dure je sais pas
combien de dizaines ou de centaines
d'années et petit à petit, on voit. Et
donc il n'y a pas à un moment donné ça
se verrait parce que comme vous savez il
y a quatre bases. Donc à un moment donné
on voit très vite s'il y a une coupure
et une remise c'est impossible. Quand
vous avez entendu les déclarations du
professeur Montagnier,
oui, c'est c'est
c'est c'est parce qu'il est vieux, c'est
parce qu'il a besoin de enfin ce n'est
pas vrai. Bon,
c'est Non, mais c'est je sais pas
pourquoi il a dit ça, mais je dis ce
n'est pas vrai. Alors, deuxièmement euh
deuxièmement, vous avez posé une
question en disant est-ce que il a pu
s'échapper ? Par définition. Euh par
définition, quelqu'un peut
un de nous quatre peut avoir un
coronavirus
hein. Un de nos 8 peut avoir un
coronavirus et et ensuite le
transmettre. Bon, qu'est-ce que ça je ne
sais pas, je ne le sais pas, je peux pas
répondre.
Revenons un peu de géopolitique puis
après on va aborder le le
l'hydrochloroxyquine.
La la chlorexyine et hydroxychloroquine.
Excusez-moi. Désolé, je me suis trompé
d'anesthésion. C'est ça.
Les États-Unis, Donald Trump Donald
Trump qui prend son petit comprimé
d'antipaluder
Donald Trump qui fait de l'esprouve.
Donald Trump en tant qu'ancien ministre
des affaires étrangères. Ça vous rassure
? Ça vous rassure pas ? Vous êtes
inquiet par rapport au futur de voir un
président des États-Unis
euh un peu en roue libre sur Twitter, ça
vous inquiète pas ? Qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire ?
Non, c'estàd que c'est
euh
moi j'ai appris la politique sur le tas,
j'ai pas fait science pot.
Moi, je suis comme voilà c'est ça, je
fais carrière politique. C'est ça,
hein.
C'est c'est avoir une carrière.
Non, non, pas du tout. J'ai dire j'ai
appris la politique sur le tas. J'ai
j'ai appris Simon Vein m'a appris
Chirac, j'ai appris donc pour ça que
j'ai fait beaucoup voilà et en fait là
ce que je vois et ce que je n'avais
jamais vu de ma vie c'est un homme qui a
à peu près tous les médias de son pays
contre
et qui arrive avec un un truc qui
s'appelle tout Twitter
et gagne des élections
et non de monter dans les sondages et
tout le monde et et plus il y a
d'articles contre lui et Il y a des
missions
je sais pas New York Times c'est c'est
un monument c'est c'est extraordinaire
les gens les qualités les qualités des
articles New York Times c'est c'est
juste exceptionnel on adorerait
comment vous expliquez cette défiance
c'est ça c'est ça
je sais pas j'ai c'est ça enfin c'est ce
qu'on voit d'ailleurs actuellement avec
ce débat d'ailleurs qui m'intéresse pas
au fond monsieur Raou c'est c'est ça
C'est
c'est ça qui moi m'impressionne au plus
haut niveau chez Trump, c'est comment il
il arrive à monter alors que tous les
journalistes sont payés en dehors de Fox
News, c'est-à-dire un tout petit toute
petite partie des journalistes sont
contre lui. Voilà, c'est tout. Donc lui
il fait ça mais les troxy chloroquines
c'est ça c'est il fait la politique
voilà donc il fait il ne fait que ça il
dit vous êtes malade mais moi j'ai un
médicament pas de problème.
C'est pas vrai. Ah ben c'est pas vrai.
Moi non moi je vous dis que c'est vrai.
Voilà c'est
c'est un peu comme avec les masques en
France.
Enfin là les masques. J'ai l'impression
que ça a pas marché. C'est ça la
différence. C'est c'est brasser de l'air
chaud scutter de la fumée.
Non c'est pas pareil parce queassur
pas du tout. Non. Je pense qu'il y a pas
de populiste. L'équipe française
aujourd'hui n'est pas populiste.
Donc on en revient à la défiance euh et
on en revient à l'hydroxychloroine
à Raou. Euh comment vous expliquer qu'il
y a une population qui sein dans deux
camps avec les proraou, les antiraou,
les antichloroines, les anti AZT, les
antiprocédures ? Comment vous expliquez
ça ?
à cause des journalistes qui ont fait un
show autour de de
ça, qui ont qu'organisé un petit peu un
sujet clivant qui permettait de faire de
l'audience. C'était quoi ? C'était des
années d'incurie de confiance politique.
C'est-à-dire que les gens n'ont plus
confiance dans leur politique, les gens
n'ont plus confiance dans leurs
journaux. Ça vient de quoi ? Non,
d'abord ça vient quand même d'une crise
sanitaire aigue euh où tout le monde a
eu peur. Il y a pas une famille qui n'a
pas eu peur parce que là, on sait
aujourd'hui que c'est temps de mortalité
euh pendant 15 jours, 3 semaines, on
s'est demandé quand même ce qui se
passait. Donc il y avait une sorte de
peur collective et il existe dans notre
subconscient la peur de la de la peste
noire. Donc ça existe dans notre
cerveau. Donc les gens ont eu peur.
Enfin que je dis les gens nous avons eu
peur. Moi le premier.
Ensuite
ensuite
il y a
des grands spécialistes qui viennent et
euh Raoul tout le monde le sait est un
des plus grands
ceux qui sont payés à ne pas avoir peur
ceux qui sont payés fa non ils ont peur
aussi parce que personne ne sait
le contraire nous les médecins, on a
souvent beaucoup plus peur que les
malades parce que on sait nous il faut
pas nous raconter l'histoire on sait ce
qui se passe. Donc ça peut ça peut être
justement extrêmement dangereux un
virus. Bon enfin bon euh il est il fait
partie de comité scientifique. C'est une
très bonne idée d'avoir fait un comité
scientifique au fond dire voilà moi je
suis pas un médecin, je suis pas
scientifique, dites-moi qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez.
Là-dessus, lui il raisonne plus du tout
comme chercheur dans un premier temps.
Il raisonne comme un médecin qui se voit
submergé par des gens qui ont, on le
connaît un peu mieux maintenant, mais
mais quand même un syndrome tableau
clinique qu'on ne connaissait pas.
C'est-à-dire des jeunes qui viennent en
gros, des vieux aussi des jeunes qui
viennent avec le tableau souvent très
mal à la tête, tricourbaturé et fièvre.
Mais un truc que moi j'avais jamais vu,
c'est docteur, j'ai une gêne pour
respirer.
D'accord. Ça je peux ça j' vu beaucoup
de ma vie.
Madame, vous allez compter jusqu'à 20
s'il vous plaît
parce que j'ai dès qu'il y a eu ça, j'ai
demandé comme tout médecin où est-ce que
je peux servir. Donc ils m'ont mis dans
le cadre de la réserve sanitaire ou 15
là où on reçoit les là où on disait aux
gens si vous avez un problème vous
téléphonez.
Donc les gens ils avaient ça. J'ai
jamais vu ça parce que elle par contre
la dame qui me dit j'ai ma gêne
respiratoire, elle compte jusqu'à 20 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10. Elle n'est pas
essouff, elle fait pas 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8.
Elle croit qu'elle a ça.
Ça, j'avais jamais vu ça. Donc je pense
que c'est d'ailleurs probablementque
non non un trouble neurologique.
C'est un sujet aujourd'hui que les
neurologues travaillent. En tout cas, je
dis pas que c'est ça, mais c'est un vrai
sujet de travail. C'est-à-dire que une
impression comme ça. Donc voyez donc
qu'est-ce qu'il voit ? C'est vraiment
très impressionnant. Et lui il est à son
IHU à Marseille donc il voit arriver des
horses de gens. Il aller voir Raou. Bon
et c'est là où il a l'idée de génie
franchement c'est que alors que l'État
français le ministère de la santé dit
"Écoutez non non non n'allez pas à
l'hôpital et puis pas de les tests c'est
que pour les médecins comme les masques,
c'est que pour les médecins. Vous testez
pas on peut pas tester de toute façon
tout le monde. On n pas la possibilité
de tester. Il dit comment ça on pas ? Le
nombre de gens qui ont des PCR à
Marseille c'est énorme. Il y a une cerme
je recommence mon truc. l'INERM, le
CNRS, INRA et cetera, les véaux. Allez
tout le monde vous testez les résultats,
il y a les queues, les fameuses que
qu'on voit à l'Hu et il teste évidemment
il tombe sur des cas précoces et les cas
précoces, il fait ce que un docteur
fait.
Traité,
il fait quoi ? Il a fait de la médecine
de guerre.
C'est ça. Il fait de la médecine de
guerre. C'est ça. Il fait il fait de la
médecine. Exactement.
C'est quoi de la médecine de guerre ?
Il fait la médecine de guerre. Il
réfléchit pas. Il dit bz on y va. Bou !
Et qu'est-ce qu'il lit ? comme il fait
la littérature en permanence comme un
tout bon médecin
mais enfin tout le monde le fait pas
quand même, il voit que il y a un
chinois en qui il a très confiance parce
que les Chinois deviennent quand même
aujourd'hui vraiment je vous dis des des
sachants quoi, des gens qui connaissent
très très bien des grands scientifiques.
Il voit qu'il donne de
l'hydroxychloroine
et il voit il y a
qui qui donnait de l'hydroxychloroin ?
Il se référenç il référit pas à
Oui, un chinois, il y a un chinois, il y
a une oui il y a une une publication
chinoise qui sort
sur la réaction. Oui, en disant chez
nous,
c'est pas une prescription hein.
Non, on dit on donne de l'hydroxy
chloroquine. C'est dire que il tombe sur
une publication chinoise. Euh j'ai j'ai
plus le nom en tête, mais un type qu'il
connaît ou qu' qui qu'il respecte dans
tête dans un journal connu en montrant
une une enquête positive. Il y en a eu
des négatives aussi niveau
il en parle des négatives.
Non mais je vous dis ce qui se passe à
l'époque, il lit il lit il lit le truc,
il lit ça. Il est vraiment médecin de
guerre.
Et là il fait une vidéo
donc oui
la fête est finie. Je non, attendez, il
fait hydroxyclorine
là, il dit aux gens, on va regarder ça.
Il va au labo, il met un tube, un truc
une vitro au labo, un virus, il
metroxychloroquine. Il y a plus
dexycloroquin dans 5 jours, 6 jours
virus.
Il y a plus de virus, pardon. Et mais ça
veut rien dire parce que pour Ebola
c'était pareil. On avait fait pareil
pour ébola, ça avait marché Invitro mais
Invivo, ça marche pas.
Donc il le fait une vivo, il refait les
PCR au bout de 5 jours, 6 jours, plus de
virus.
Ça marche une vivo et c'est là où il
fait ça. Bon alors ça évidemment c'est
vrai.
On va en parler après si vous voulez
pour être extrêmement honnête c'est
c'est un vrai sujet ça mais il dit fin
de partie. Bon très bien.
Mais ce que je veux dire c'est il fait
quelque chose qui est quoi qui est très
très simple au fond.
il prend les il les teste, il les
dépiste tout, il les met en 14, il leur
donne un antiviral qui s'appelle
hydroxygloroine et un autre antibiotique
qui s'appelle la zitromycine. Pourquoi ?
ce qu'il faut faire d'ailleurs très
souvent dans les virus respiratoires
parce que vous finissez par faire une
surinfection bronchique et vous mourrez
souvent plus de ça. D'ailleurs, je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup de vieux de vieux de
personnes âgées pardon qui ont la grippe
et qui décèdent de de qui qui décèdent
de
de grippe parce que par la surinfection
bronchique. En tout cas, moi à mon âge
maintenant, je m'aperçois quand j'ai la
grippe, je me prends un antibiotique
avec pour justement ne pas avoir de
surinfection bronchique.
Quelle famille vous prenez des
macrolides ? justement je vais changer,
je vais prendre je vais prendre des
macrolides mais bon mais donc j'ai fait
beaucoup de progrès de médecine comme
tout le monde d'ailleurs pendant cette
période. Alors euh
il fait ça c'est tout. Et donc il teste,
il dépiste tout, il isole et il traite
comme on fait depuis le 18e siècle hein
ou 19e siècle en gros c'est un peu plus
loin. Bon sauf que tous les pays qui ont
fait ça,
même ceux qui n'ont pas fait
d'asitromicine, ceux qui ont juste
soigné quoi, hein, ils ont pris les
gens, ils ont isolé et ils ont soigné
peu d'oxygène, un peu de truc un peu bon
soigne
qu'en fait qu'a fait le reste de la
France ?
Allô ? Moi j'étais je faisais partie je
faisais partie du groupe puisque j'étais
homme. Je demande qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire monsieur ? Qu'est-ce que je
réponds ? Bah écoutez, si c'est juste
une gêne thoracique et que il compte
bien jusqu'à 10 ou à 20, mais vous dites
"Écoutez monsieur, vous restez où madame
? Vous restez chez vous et vous nous
rappelez s' a un problème." J'ai dû dire
ça, je sais pas 400 fois moi. Donc vous
vivez avec qui ? Vous êtes pas seul
quand même. Non non non, nous sommes
cinq à la maison. Il y a ma femme, mes
trois enfants, il y a pas de problème.
Ce qui est sûr, c'est que la femme, mes
trois enfants ont été contaminé en
faisant ça. Donc nous avons fait, nous
avons une stratégie qui a goûté une
contamination intrafamiliale,
ce que Raoul n'a pas fait. Et c'est ce
qui je termine là-dessus
sur votre idée de de la mortalité parce
que évidemment les gens disent j'ai vu
l'autre jour sur le plateau
départ c'était la défiance. Oui oui
quand même je termine quand même
là-dessus sur le chiffre quand même.
C'est important parce que les gens
disent monsieur arrêtez Raoul c'est la
rigolade il a 05 % de mortalité c'est
d'ailleurs le taux de mortalité
c'est c'est je n'importe quoi
5 ou 3.1
Non mais justement c'est justement c'est
ça qui est intéressant, c'est ça dépend
de quoi on parle. Le seul truc qui est
important c'est les les gens
hospitalisés parce que on hospitalise
toujours pour la même raison. Donc on
hospitalise pas plus à Marseille, à
Paris, à Lyon, à Nant. Et donc si vous
regardez les gens qui décèdent à
l'hôpital là vous avez vraiment une
différence mais c'est 3,1 à Marseille,
pas uniquement Raou. assistance publique
hôpitaux de Marseille qui faisait
d'ailleurs le protocole Raoul mais bon
manteau
mais qui faisaitine plus hydroxy que le
requin 3,1
France 17,6 ou 7
île de France
non non
France
je imagine
17 17,6 de quoi de de
de mortalité sur les gens hospitalisés
d'accord
donc je parle bien des gens qui meurent
à l'hôpital du Covid COVID chez des gens
qui ont été hospitalisés pour Covid,
c'est quelque chose de comparable.
Donc à la louche, si je dois résumer ça
trivialement, vous êtes hospitalisé
COVID, vous avez 25 20 % de chance de
claquer.
C'est ça.
17,6 %.
Si si je vous suis bien, c'est ça. OK.
Et oui, enfin c'est c'est prouvé hein.
C'est c'est les chiffres du ministère de
la santé. Ouais.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi ils ont retiré le
l'hydrochlorexyquine
en en prescription pour traiter le
Covid-19 ?
Alors, c'est ça. Ça c'est un ça
s'appelle un syndrome de c'est c'est
c'est le syndrome de précaution.
Vous avez
principe
le principe excusez-moi. Mais oui, ce
que j'appelle c'est c'est c'est c'est
mon tout à fait c'est dans mon
subconscient. et c'est le principe de
précaution qui n'est vraiment quelque
chose là dans le cas particulier qui ne
fonctionne pas. Pourquoi ? Parce que sur
les 4000 cas d'abord de qu'il a, il n'y
a pas d'accident cardio-vasculaire. Ce à
quoi on peut répondre ? Mais c'est vrai
pour être honnête, ils ont 44 ans moyen
d'âge ou 50 ans et donc ils n'ont pas
d'accident parce qu'il n'ont pas et
c'est vrai. C'est-à-dire qu'au fond
Raou, il donne des médicaments à des
gens qui sont en stade précoce tout en
enlevant ceux qui ont des
contre-indications de l'hydroxy
chloroquine. Il fait un
électrocardiogramme au départ.
C'est un peu biaisé ça non ? Puisque
c'est c'est pas que c'est bizé, c'est
qu'il fait son métier, c'est que
l'hydroxychloroine, vous ne devez pas le
donner à quelqu'un qui ne doit pas en
avoir. C'est très dangereux.
L'étude discovery, tout ça, ça sert à
rien.
Alors non, non mais discovery, c'est
encore autre chose. Mais ce que je veux
dire, c'est que le land 7 par contre
cette étude rétrospective non
randomisée, donc ce qu'on a beaucoup
rapproché reproché à Didier Raou, c'est
que cette étude n'est pas randomisée.
C'est vrai,
aveugle
est aveugle. Donc c'est vrai, elle n'est
pas elle n'est pas à l'aveugle
justement. Elle n'est pas randomisée.
Donc l'étude du Land 7 qui a tout fait
casser. Ça y est, le doxychloroquine est
à jeté. Euh surtout n'en donnez pas.
C'est ça arrive la veille de l'ascension
et sur une étude de 93000 cas au passage
le dernier
malade rentré dans l'étude c'est le 14
avril
et l'étude est publiée le 19 mai. Alors
moi je sais pas comment on fait là mais
s'il en a pas 400 ou 500 petites pour
travailler je sais pas comment elles
sont payées et par qui ? Je sais que ça
coûte très cher quand même, ça c'est sû.
Pourquoi vous dites par qui,
hein ?
Pourquoi vous dites par qui ?
Je ne sais pas. Je ne sais pas qui a les
moyens de faire aujourd'hui, je ne sais
pas qui a les moyens aujourd'hui de
payer une étude qui finit
dont on finit l'introduction du dernier
malade, l'admission du dernier malade le
14 avril de le sortir dans le l mai. Je
peux vous assurer que déjà ça c'est une
prouesse extraordinaire mais qui coûte
très cher, ça c'est sûr.
Deuxièmement,
on ne sait pas combien
les gens ont pris d'hydroxychloroquine.
La posologie, moi si je vous donne 2 g
de de d'hydroxychloroquine, même à vous
grand gaillard, je peux vous assurer que
ça va vous secouer, hein. Et si je vous
donne 4
déjà à 200 mg, je vomis.
Oui, c'est ça. Donc déjà, voilà, il y a
déjà des effets secondaires comme ça.
Donc lui, en donne 600 mais 600 Voilà.
Mais 2 g, c'est déjà un taux extrêmement
c'est limite, c'est c'est très très
limite. 4 vous vous pouvez aussi vous
suicider aussi. Bon donc on ne sait pas,
on ne sait pas. On ne sait pas, c'est
écrit, tout le monde dit que c'est
extraordinaire. L' 7, on ne sait pas.
C'est bien. Ensuite, vous regardez les
gens à qui il l'a donné. C'est pas du
tout les mêmes que ce que donne monsieur
Raou. Monsieur Raul le donne au début,
les deux premiers jours, trois premiers
jours là.
Pas que ça.
Non, mais il donne plus la zitromicine
en plus.
D'accord. Est-ce qu'il y a eu des études
? Non mais ça veut dire non mais je
termine le land 7 lui c'est au 9e 10e
jour donc voilà donc arrêton il faut
quand même être un peu sérieux aussi
quand même c'est je ne veux pas moi à
tout prix dire que l'hydroxycloroine
c'est bien. Je dis simplement que le
procès qui est fait quand même bizarre
je trouve très bizarre.
Est-ce que vous pouvez me donner des
exemples d'interaction médicamenteuse de
de molécules qui pourraient avoir des
effets délétaires sur la santé ? des
choses communes qu'on peut prendre et si
on en mixe deux, c'est pas bon.
Oui, bien sûr.
Vous avez des idées ?
Oui, oui, j'ai j'ai plein d'idé. Oui,
j'ai plein d'idées. J'ai j'ai plein
d'idées. Mais
donnez-moi deux exemples.
Ben, je vais vous donner tout de suite
euh
je vais vous donner euh
Non, mais un qui pourrait parler très
fortement,
c'est quoi ? la cocaïne avec les béta
bloquants, c'est ça ? Non, je peux je
peux vous donner justement oui, vous
parlez des blab bloquants et bien je
peux vous donner bétabloquant et
corticoïde.
Bétabloquant, corticoïde, c'est pas bon.
Mais bétabloquant et corticoïde c'est
une catastrophe.
D'accord. Et à votre avis, si je
voudrais si je vous dis
hydrochloricidine avec azt
avec azytromicine
azytromicine
ouais.
Est-ce que est-ce que c'est pas bon ?
Mais la preuve, il a donné 4000 euh vous
connaissez Recovery, vous m'avez parlé
de Discovery de Recovery. Recovery,
c'est la grande étude qui est faite au
au Royaume-Uni avec hydroxychloroquine.
Pas un avec des milliers de jour, pas un
accident
avec hydroxychlorocine et AZT.
Euh je il faudrait regarder il y a
hydroxyclorine.
Ma question ma question en fait c'est
c'est les deux. Oui, vous avez non, là
vous avez raison, c'est que la
zittromicine a aussi des complications
cardi-vasculaires.
Donc la question en préparant cette
émission depuis le 15 janvier où on
était déjà positionné sur le sujet, on
écoute, on n pas pris position, on prend
pas position, on écoute les gens.
Quand on écoute le professeur Raou,
il parle toujours d'hydroxychloroquine,
de chloroine, sans préciser que il y a
une double thérapie, une bithérapie, il
y a de la ZT. Et sur certaines études
qu'on a pu lire, il est bien marqué en
gros que
la chloricidine, ça fait 90 ans qu'on
enfile à tout le monde. Il y a 36
millions de doses qui ont été données
l'année dernière dans le monde. Mais
quand on la mixe avec la ZT là tout de
suite c'est on rentre dans une autre
dimension.
Alors pharmacologiquement, vous avez
tout à fait raison. Euh,
pharmacologiquement euh la ZT peut avoir
des laitromicine peut avoir des donner
des troubles du du rythme euh le trouble
cardiaque et type c'est des
myofibrulations du ventricul du
ventriculation. C'est ça. Et et quand
hydroxy chloroine, c'est l'augmentation
de ce qu'on appelle l'espace QT sur
électrocardiogramme. Bon,
quand vraiment vous faites un
électrocardiogramme avant
et que vous le faites pendant et que
vous le faites après, vous n'avez aucun
risque dans cette double dans cette
double. Donc là, on parle à l'hôpital,
c'est facile de le faire, on peut pas le
faire à l'extérieur.
À l'hôpital, on peut mettre un hter
faire un il y a beaucoup de médecins
libéraux qui font des
électrocardiogrammes. Je vous dis quand
même qu'au passageoup
beaucoup de gens qui
pendant la prise 2 he avant la prise, 2
heure. C'est pas comme ça. Mais pas du
tout. C'est pas à ce point. Euh non non
ne ne croyez pas que les conséquences
euh les conséquences euh cardiologiques
sont comme ça. Mais enfin vous avez
raison monsieur le principe. Donc
regardons sur 4000 cas qu'il a pris. Il
n'y a pas un seul accident. Donc il y a
un rythmologue qui était là. Bon
ceux qui ont pris euh ceux ceux qui ont
fait les différentes études aujourd'hui
en France on en a fait. Alors, j'ai vu
qu'aujourd'hui ça été ça été arrêté mais
enfin il y en a eu quand même beaucoup
qui ont été fait c'est sur 10 jours hein
n'oubliez pas 10 jours. Donc tomber sur
des trouble vraiment montrer que c'est
un poison en 10 jours. L'association
franchement je personne ne me fera
croire ça. Par contre, je crois que le
donner à une personne qui a une forme
grave, qui est âgé
ou
âgé,
c'est-à-dire quelqu'un de 75 ans avec
des comorbidités qui apprenait justement
des médicaments pour l'hypertension
artérielle, pour l'obésité, pour le
diabète et qui en plus a des troubles du
rythme enfin ou un électrocardiogramme
qui n'est pas normal. Là, je pense que
jamais je ne donnerai cette association
et c'est pour ça que je regrette si vous
voulez qu'il n'y ait pas la clarté sur
ce qui disent parce que il faut qu'il
nous disent exactement les les
électrocardiogrammes de Did Raul, ils
sont à la ils sont ils sont à la
disposition de tout le monde.
Malheureusement, les
électrocardiogrammes dont on nous parle
dans Land 7, personne ne peut les voir.
Alors, c'est ça le problème, vous
comprenez ? Donc, je crois qu'il faut
être quand même extrêmement honnête.
Donc il y a des il y a un effet des des
problèmes dans ce que vous avez dit sur
vous avez posé les vrais sujet et c'est
vrai, c'est bien de les poser mais on
peut le faire de la clarté. On peut
répondre à la clarté. À Marseille, il le
répondent de la clarté. Donc il faudrait
que ceux qui attaquent puissent répondre
à la clarté aussi. Et et ce qui
m'ennuie, voyez, pour aller au fond de
ma pensée, ce qui m'ennuie, c'est que
c'est la première fois quand même qu'on
voit un truc comme ça aussi aussi.
Alors, c'est vrai qu' a c'est vrai qu'il
y a certainement
la la personnalité de Didou, mais enfin
quand même, je trouve étonnant. Regardez
ce qui se passe au niveau des
laboratoires.
Vous avez des laboratoires qui avaient
des molécules antivirales.
Non, vous avez plein, vous avez quatre
ou cinq. Euh vous avez les deux du sida,
vous avez le rétro le remd zivir de
Guiliade, vous avez vous avez plein
et évidemment c'est un jackpot parce que
si leurs molécules marchent dans une
épidémie comme celle-là mondiale,
c'est c'est s'appelle jackpot.
Mais c'est des gens qui travaillent
aujourd'hui dans une manière très
particulière. Ils travaillent en fait
dans la bourse des gens qui travaillent
dans le capitalisme financier.
Et comment marche aujourd'hui ces boîtes
? Comment elles sont évaluées ? Elles
sont évaluées par la bourse. Si jamais
il y a un effet secondaire de je sais
plus quel médicament dans un grand
labou, l'action perd 25 % dans la nuit.
Si à l'inverse un un laboratoire dit
"Moi, j'ai trouvé le médicament
fantastique pour le pour le pour le pour
le Covid et bien son sa valeur prend 4
milliards. C'est ce qui s'est passé pour
Guiléad. Et puis ensuite, il y a
quelqu'un qui dit "Ah ben non, mais en
déficitif ça marche pas." Ben s'appelle
repère 4 milliards. Vous avez monsieur
Bell qui est un homme exceptionnel
d'ailleurs, un français qui est parti à
Boston et qui a monté Moderna qui est
une des plus grandes et belles
d'ailleurs boîtes de bibliothèque dans
le monde. Chapeau d'avoir fait ça. En
fait l'autre jour, il dit "Moi, je vais
avoir le vaccin contre le virus contre
le virus le Covid." C'est bien. Alors
bon, mais qu'est-ce que vous avez,
monsieur ? Vous vous savez, vous l'avez
trouvé ? Ah non, je vais le trouver mais
je vais vous montrer. Moi, j'ai déjà 9
cas en phase 1. Vous savez ce que c'est
la phase 1 ? C'est des gens normaux. On
regarde juste si s'appelle safety.
Est-ce que il y a C'est la sécurité ?
Juste la sécurité, c'est vous mourrez
pas, vous n'avez pas de bouton, vous
n'avez pas d'insuffisance rénale,
insuffisance cardiaque, les cheveux
tombent pas, vous nez pas rouge, vert ou
bleu. Bon voilà, il dit non mais
regardez, tout s'est bien passé. Vous
savez combien il a monté sa boîte ? 30 %
de la nuit. 30 % de valeur boursière. Je
c je crois qu'il était enfin il y a
plusieurs dizaines de milliards. Donc ça
voyez ça me fait peur parce que je ne
dis pas attention je ne dis pas que
c'est siquin doit si on doit voir dans
un essai parfait qui ne marche pas, je
serai le premier à à le dire. Je je suis
un scientifique.
Des essais qui prouvent que ça
fonctionnait pas.
Mais il y en a mais il y a aucun il y a
aucune preuve qui montre que ça ne
fonctionne pas. justement dans le cas où
on le on s'en sert au début dans les
premiers jours et chez des gens qui
n'ont pas d'accident qui n'ont pas
interdiction je dirais de de
contreindication cardio-ovasculaire.
Donc voilà et avec les homcines en
effet. Donc je pense que aujourd'hui là
on est dans un en fait c'est c'est
terrible parce que c'est il y a tout au
fond. Il y a le virus, la peur que nous
avons collective, il y a une bagarre de
chiffonier sur le plan boursier,
beaucoup d'argent, il y a des morts,
la puissance de l'État.
Il y a une puissance de l'État et et il
y a c'est terrible quoi. Enfin, c'est
c'est un moment difficile que nous
passons là. Mais mais il faut tenir, il
faut tenir, il faut il faut expliquer.
C'est pour ça que je suis là pour 2h,
pour 3h, pour 5h, ça m'est égal. Je je
vous voyez, je moi je suis pas voilà,
moi je
la vie m'a appris que la vérité était la
seule chose importante.
Euh quel est-ce que vous connaissez
Didier Raou personnellement ?
Alors je l'ai connu, tout connais très
peu au fond. Je connais très peu.
Pas un ami.
Non non non, nous sommes jamais partis
en vacances ensemble. On a jamais dîner
ensemble. On a
C'est pas sa date d'anniversaire ?
Non, je connais pas sa date
d'anniversaire. Euh il m'a fait le le
l'honneur de
combien temps que vous le connaissez ?
Je connais depuis une vingtaine d'années
euh mais sur le plan scientifique,
voyez, je veux dire c'est mais
il m'a fait il m'a fait l'honneur il y a
euh plusieurs années d'être avec des
grands scientifiques euh d'être Mais
moi, il m'a pas pris comme grand
scientifique par je suis pas un grand
scientifique mais euh
simplement votre réseau.
Mais non plus, c'est parce que je suis
un ancien ministre d'affaires des de la
santé. Je vais vous expliquer pourquoi.
Parce que c'est ça qui est important. Il
m'a il m'a pris donc au à son conseil
d'administration de l'IU et j'ai vu
qu'il y avait beaucoup de gens qui qui
lui a pris. Oui, c'est lui. Oui. Et il y
a beaucoup de gens qui qui disent
justement que je veux pas être je veux
pas je suis je suis partiante puisque et
j'ai je dis du bien de ça parce que je
suis alors je voudrais dire c'est très
important ça que monsieur Delfi
qui est le président du conseil
scientifique qui homme d'une grande
honnêteté enfin un grand scientifique un
type très honnête qui est aussi lui
aussi
à la au conseil d'administration de la
fondation de l'IU.
Il a il est complètement opposé
justement à Raoul sur ça. Et pourquoi on
y est ? Parce que Raoul est un très très
grand scientifique. Je n'ai jamais
touché un centime 1 centime de cette
fondation de cette IHU. Je n'ai jamais
été invité
avec un billet d'avion. Je n'ai jamais
été invité à un restaurant ni un café.
Jamais. Ça m'est jamais arrivé. Donc
bénéficier de Laura de de l'ashu.
Non, même pas. Non. C'est pas marqué sur
votre carte de visite.
Non, jamais. Et puis non puis non non
mais vous avez raison de poser la
question. Mais non parce que moi ma vie
est ailleurs aujourd'hui et comment
c'est financé l'Hu ?
L'Hu est financé essentiellement par du
public beaucoup d'argent public. Il y a
eu à l'époque c une fondation d'ailleurs
certains laboratoires qui ont pu
d'ailleurs donner mais si vous voulez
c'est très peu au fond. Lui il gagne son
argent essentiellement par le public. Il
a toujours été c'est pas un homme
d'argent d'ailleurs l'achu comment c'est
financé
par le public beaucoup par du public
mais je je peux pas vous dire exactement
toutes les tranches
sur site internet sur le site internet
de l'Hou on a du mal à récupérer les
données financières mais vous pouvez
vous pouvez les avoir enfin je suis sûr
que monsieur R vous les donnera ou
le conseil d'administration il sait
combien il y a d'argent qui passe dans
les tuyaux il sait comment c'est employé
com
Non mais moi je je ne suis ne gère pas
du tout je suis pas du tout un
gestionnaire je regarde
vous si là-bas uniquement parce que
C'est l'oblasi ou
non ? Je oui c'est ça en fait je gère
parce que je je regarde essentiellement
l'affaire scientifique. Je suis
extrêmement intéressé fa une fois je
suis allé faire je allé une fois faire
une conférence sur mon travail aux
Nations- Unies. Donc je je mais je vais
ajouter quelque chose, c'est que donc il
y a des gens qui ont dit ça mais donc je
les rassure tout de suite, c'est je
pensais le contraire de Raoul, je le
dirai.
Je gagne rien rien du tout à être au
conseil d'administration des IHU. Euh
par contre, il y a beaucoup de gens qui
parlent de cette crise qui eux
euh ont touché de l'argent des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques. Euh
quand vous étiez ministre ou quand vous
étiez Toubi BIB, vous avez touché du blé
de laboratoire. Moi je alors non
justement c'est intéressant parce que
quelqu'un a écrit des choses entre je
n'ai jamais touché d'argent de laborque
sauf lorsque en effet quand j'avais 25
ans ou 26 ans euh les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques m'ont invité c'était
l'époque avant les lois euh de les
miennes d'ailleurs celle de couchner et
les miennes euh qui interdit qui ont
interdit à un moment donné au
laboratoire pharmaceutique de payer les
jeunes médecins ou les vieux médecins
les médecins d'aller dans des congrès.
Voilà, ça c'est vrai. Ensuite, il y
avait mais enfin je n'ai jamais été prêt
si vous voulez des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques pour la bonne unique
raison que ma vie a été justement et on
va en parler j'espère
d'être
c'est une des raisons d'ailleurs pour
lesquelles j'avais les Américains pas
toujours pour moi le jour de l'élection
de l'OMS parce que je fais partie de
ceux qui pensent que c'est une honte
le système de la santé mondiale est une
honte. Donc je je vais je vais le dire
ici et et c'est important. Chaque fois
que j'essayé de le dire en France, ça
n'intéresse pas. Moi ce qui intéresse
beaucoup les observateurs, c'est si je
suis pour monsieur un tel ou pour
monsieur un tel ou pour monsieur un tel.
Mais le plus important pour moi de ma
vie, c'est de dire ce que je vais vous
dire.
La santé mondiale est une honte
aujourd'hui. Pourquoi ? Parce que si un
médicament, je vais prendre par exemple
celui que je connais le mieux, c'est le
sida.
Si sur le sida un nouveau médicament
arrive
et si ce médicament là est
exceptionnellement efficace
et sauve des vies, c'est extraordinaire
pour celui qui a le sida qui va le
prendre. Malheureusement, il n'y a que
celui qui est dans le pays aux
États-Unis, en Europe, en Australie et
quelques pays riches qui pourra se le
payer parce qu'il vaut 150000 ou 100000
dollars par an, d'accord ? euros par an.
Celui qui a pas la chance d'habiter là
mais qui va habiter à Adisab Bamako ou
à Gadou, lui il doit attendre entre 10
et 20 ans pour que le brevet de cette de
ce médicament qui sauve, qui est le plus
cher, qui est le plus efficace, qui est
le plus extraordinaire, il attend 15
ans. Mais le problème c'est qu'il attend
pas 15 ans parce qu' il meurt
entre-temps.
Donc pour moi, c'est un crime contre
l'humanité. Pourquoi ? Parce que vous
avez, c'est comme un pistolet, c'est
comme si vous tirez, vous avez le
médicament
mais vous lui donnez pas. Évidemment, il
peut pas le payer lui puisqu'il gagne
entre 1 et 3 dollars par jour. Son pays
ne peut pas le pays parce que souvent
c'est une dictature de toute façon qui
donne de l'argent plutôt à son chef
d'état que à son ministre de la santé
ou des partis politiques
ou oui en fait c'est la même chose.
C'est la même chose. Il se gave. Bon,
très bien, on le sait par la corruption
et donc on se trouve on se retrouve dans
une situation hubesque
où vous avez des laboratoires qui
prennent très souvent d'ailleurs
les les les données et les découvertes
du public. Euh une Serme, c'est un RS
pour la France, un AH, NHK pour les
États-Unis ou autre chose, payé par les
impôts qui font le médicament et qui
ensuite le vendent très très cher pour
les pays riches et qui ne regardent même
pas les pays pauvres qui peuvent pas le
payer. Mais ça c'est pas la faute du du
laboratoire pharmaceutique. C'est trop
facile de dire les labos sont des
salots. Non, c'est nous, c'est les
hommes politiques, c'est vous les
citoyens. C'est nous qui pensons que la
santé mondiale, c'est comme ça. Il y a
des gens qui sont du bon côté, ceux qui
sont du mauvais. Donc moi, un jour,
grâce d'ailleurs à médecin sans
frontière, j'ai décidé en 2008
de m'attaquer à ça. Et j'ai dit,
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ? Il faut
faire le le medicines pitant pool.
Medicines comme medicines en anglais.
Python comme le brevet. P a t e n t.
Pool p o l. Ça s'appelle la communauté
de brevet. Donc si vous allez qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ? Ça veut dire bonjour
monsieur Pfizer
votre dernier médicament j'ai
Sanofi
hein
ouanofianofi ou Glaxo
ou Bayer ou Roche ou enfin tous
mais voilà mais c'est Pizer c'est quand
même le plus gros hein. Je vous dis ça
parce que j'ai juste allé le voir donc
je sais ce qui m'est arrivé. Donc je le
voir en 2008 j'étais un peu j'étais plus
ministre c'était plus compliqué et et
donc il me reçoit parce que j'étais
ancien ministre d'affaires étrangères.
Voilà tout ça se passe bien. Et je dis
j'ai un exemple j'ai j'ai une idée. Le
médicament que vous vendez très cher,
ben vous continuez à le vendre très
cher. Ça ça me dérange pas. Au fond,
c'est une un arrangement entre le
ministère assurance maladie. Enfin,
c'est votre problème, c'est votre sujet.
Je l'ai fait, j'ai été ministre.
C'est c'est leur subvention.
Oui, j'ai été ministre de la santé. Je
sais très bien comment ça marche. Je je
je vous parle pas de ça, monsieur.
Ça marche comment ?
Ben, ça marche par par une discussion
qu'ils ont. Vous le voulez le
médicament, vous le voulez pas. Bon,
enfin comme les pays sont riches, ils
payent. Enfin, on peut en parler des
heures, mais heureusement, on a mis en
place, on a mis en place une agence du
médicament qui le fait. C'est plus le
ministre. Avant, c'était le ministre.
C'est plus le ministre. Ça c'est moi et
Simon Veille. Simon Veille et moi pardon
qui qui l'avons voulu. C'est plus le
ministre qui fait ce ce genre de troc.
Enfin bon, c'est un troc mais on le
fait, on paye. Par contre, monsieur Fer,
je voulais vous dire que j'ai eu une
idée, c'est que le même jour que on l'a
à Toulouse, à Paris, à Oslo et à Madrid
et à New York, on pourrait le mettre en
même temps le même jour à 10aba, mais si
vous êtes d'accord, vous donnez la
licence à un génériqueur tout de suite.
Mais vous vous moquez de moi, monsieur ?
C'est c'est
une caméra cachée c'est et je suis sorti
pratiquement manu militarie c'était
terrible. C'est je suis parti j'ai dit
que j'ai mis 15 15 minutes. Bon
j'ai fait pareil chez Glaxo à Londres
j'ai été viré.
Comment ils ont été polis pas polis ?
J'ai été poli. On disait écoutez merci
beaucoup mais non c'est pas dans nous
c'est pas dans notre politique. Merci
beaucoup. On y réfléchira par contre
c'est très intéressant.
Faites-nous un petit mail.
Voilà. Faites-nous un mail puis monsieur
directeur vous pouvez raccompagner
monsieur excusez-moi vous savez on est
très pressé ici très occupé
et j'avais amené d'ailleurs un copain
des ONG euh Power of
s'appelle
Stamp and Poverty, le patron de Stamp
and Poverty, un britannique, un ONG
exceptionnel. il était venu avec moi euh
pour le vivre et euh euh et on était
allé même chez un chez un banquier, je
sais plus Stanley ou ensemble pour voir
pour discuter de ça, de cette idée. Et
puis un jour
de fil en aiguille, il y a un grand un
conseiller du Santé mondiale d'Obama qui
apprend ce que nous faisons sur le P and
Pool. Il dit "Mais le président a lu de
trois articles que vous avez fait, il
nous a demandé ce que c'était. Euh et
nous, on sait pas lui répondre.
Est-ce que vous voulez venir à
Washington ? Mo j'étais à New York euh
nous expliquer. Donc j'ai expliqué
pendant 3h.
Qui c'est qui a payé le billet d'avion ?
Comment ?
Moi. Moi c'était pas d'ailleurs un
billet d'avion. C'était le le train que
vous devez connaître peut-être entre New
York et qui est épouvantable. C'est bien
bien moins bien que notre TGV à nous. En
fait, c'est les trains américains. Bon,
ils sont épouvantables. Et donc, je suis
allé et euh j'ai été reçu par ce
conseiller et 15 autres personnes dans
le dans le dans le bâtiment
administratif à côté de la Maison
Blanche que les gens connaissent quand
ils sont à Washington. Et euh il me je
parle pendant 3h 4h avec euh ce ces
gens-là et puis ils me disent "Écoutez,
on va en parler au président."
à ma stupéfaction,
il y a eu un website sur le website de
la Maison Blanche, il y a eu Barack
Obama et Joe Biden sont derrière l'idée.
Ils sont d'accord pour le patent pool.
Et bien en juillet
2009, nous avons signé avec Guiléad,
vous voyez l'histoire est assez drôle
maintenant avec Gilad, puis avec Pizer,
puis avec Daxo, puis avec Johnson et
Johnson, puis avec R et cetera grâce à
la pression. Bien aujourd'hui, j'ai
l'honneur de vous dire, c'est peut-être
je suis dont je suis le plus fier de ma
vie, c'est que le plus grand, on a fait
ça avec des ONG, hein, les les le
meilleur des médicaments contre le sida,
contre la tuberculose et contre les
hépatites, c'est le même jour à Paris, à
New York, à Londres qu'à Alisabeba parce
que c'est le patent pool medicine patent
pool patent pool et pour moi c'est
extrêmement important de l'avoir fait
euh parce que
et c'est une c'était une injustice
effrayante. Alors maintenant, la
question c'est de savoir si on peut
continuer à le faire avec par exemple
les anticancéreux parce que plus
l'espérance de vie augmente en Afrique
par exemple, plus vous avez de cancer.
le cancer va devenir les maladies non
transmissibles, les maladies chroniques
comme le cancer, le diabète vont devenir
plus importantes bientôt que les
maladies infectieuses. Donc voilà,
c'était pour vous dire ça. C'était pour
vous dire que je suis extrêmement engagé
dans la lutte contre enfin pour
la forabilité, la la bord le fait que
les que le fait que les médicaments
soient abordables partout dans le monde,
c'est extrêmement important. C'est
extrêmement important pour moi. Euh
c'est de mes racines euh dont on parlait
tout à l'heure qui reviennent. Mais euh
j'y j'y je pense qu'on va y arriver. Euh
euh votre expérience aux États-Unis euh
pour ça, il y a il y a certains
traitements aux États-Unis euh euh qui
sont 100 fois plus chers qu'au Canada.
Pourquoi donc ?
Ah ben c'est très simple. C'est par Mais
juste je réponds pour pour les
internautes qui nous écoutent, c'est
donc medicines patayonpool.org je crois.
Enfin bon, c'est je crois que c'est
extrêmement important parce que c'est ce
que j'ai fait de de plus important, je
pense dans ma petite vie aidée. C'est
c'est donc en tant que président
d'united que je l'ai fait. C'est United
qu'il a qu' a qu' a créé maintenant
c'est indépendant.
Bill Gates dans United ? Non.
Non. Oui. Bill Gates la fondation Bill
Gates et d'ailleurs, j'avais des
problèmes avec Bill Gates à ce momentlà
parce que Bill Gates, la fondation
Gates, elle était pas pour au départ,
elle était pas en faveur de la création.
Ils sont pas si philanthropes que ça
de mettre mais non moi j'ai un problème
c'est queils avaient il faut reconnaître
Sarkozi était pour alors qu'il y avait
Sanofille Gordon Brown est au conseil
d'administration ou son son représentant
bien sûr était pour alors qu'il y a pleu
il y avait évidemment tous les africains
étaient pour c'est évident le Brésil
était pour la Norvège était pour les ONG
bien sûr étaient pour et puis j'ai la
fondation Gates
et la fondation Gates c'était pas pour
donc je dis mais attendez
Vous pouvez pas dire d'un côté que vous
êtes philanthrope et pas ça. Et donc une
grande explication pour les Américains,
le brevet c'est la base du pays. Il faut
il faut comprendre la culture
américaine. Le le le brevet c'est la
base. Il dit Microsoft c'est quoi ? Cit
c'est c'est un brevet. Donc si tu
commences à m'expliquer que le brevet on
peut le balancer comme ça n'importe où,
là c'est autre chose. Donc j'ai expliqué
bon effectif c'est passé, il a voté et
ça a marché.
Revenons à l'HU.
Comment vous faites pour contrôler le le
docteur Raou ? Comment il gère l'ashu ?
Comment ça se passe ? C'est une fois par
an, deux fois par an, il y a des gens
qui viennent,
il y a plusieurs administration, il y a
plusieurs conseil d'administration et je
dois reconnaître que je ne suis donné
mon pouvoir à plusieurs reprises au
conseil d'administration. À qui
je l'ai donné ? À à Didy Raou.
Donc il s'auto contrôle.
Non, enfin il y a beaucoup d'autres
personnes que lui que euh mais moi je
j'ai confiance en lui et donc je lui
donne mon pouvoir.
Est-ce que Est-ce que Didier Raoul a des
casseroles ?
À mon avis aucune.
Il a jamais eu tritouillé des petites
études. Il a jamais tritouillé des
images sur ses études.
À ma connaissance, aucune.
Jamais.
D'accord.
euh quand on quand on a préparé le le
l'émission euh on a contacté les ce que
ce que les journalistes appellent les
les antiaou
et on nous a décrit Did Raoud comme
quelqu'un de
on peut pas trop lui accorder notre
confiance
pour vous.
Non mais vous avez des choses précises
parce que
Allons-y. Non parce que vous pouvez pas
dire vous pouvez pas faire comme
on a eu un très un très mauvais retour
sur lui.
D'accord. il a trafiqué ses études que
machin c'est
Oui. Alors ça il faut faire attention
parce que
il a jamais trafiqué d'études. Non mais
moi j'ai vu les j'ai vu le le seul
reportage que j'ai vu sur Raou c'est
celui de qui est fait par BFM
et donc j'ai vu des gens un peu masqué
qui disait ce que je peux comprendre
d'ailleurs par ailleurs je enfin qui
disait des chercheurs qui disaient
les cadences sont effrayantes il nous
prend pour ceci pour cela et cetera il
faut à tout prix faire des
études faire des publications
d'accord mais Ça ça c'est moi ça me
c'est quoi ? C'est de la jalousie c'est
quoi ? Oui. Non mais c'est ça, il y a
peut-être il y a des gens qui sont
aigris, il y a peut-être des gens qui
sont C'est vrai, mais enfin quand on
voit la fidélité des gens qui retourent,
vous savez quand vous regardez un chef
d'équipe, ce sera vrai pour vous un
jour. Vous êtes très jeune mais vous
verrez vous vous verrez la fidélité des
gens autour de vous. Si depuis 10 ans,
20 ans, 30 ans vous avez la même équipe
globalement, ce qui est le cas de Raoul.
Les gens qui partent pas, 90 % des gens
qui travaillent Rault restent avec
Raoul. C'est bon signe pour vous. Euh
c'est rare les gens en politique c'est
pareil hein, c'est rare les gens qui ont
toujours les mêmes personnes autour
d'eux. Donc euh je pense qu'il fait pas
l'unanimité parce que c'est comme les
gens comme t toutes ces personnes-là,
c'est normal qu'il ait des ennemis. Mais
s'il a des casseroles, il faut les
donner, il faut me le dire. Moi lesquels
? et je c'est important pour tout le
monde mais je ne crois pas je ne pense
pas qu'il a né je pense d'abord c'est un
homme qui n'est pas un homme d'argent
c'est un homme qui a une vie simple
c'est un homme qui
qui je sais en tout cas je connais
l'hôtel il m'a donné rendez-vous deux ou
trois fois où il descend à Paris qui est
un tris étoiles c'est même pas un 4
étoiles je veux dire voilà c'est
quelqu'un qui a une vie simple
comment vous expliquez que l'étude du
professeur Peron a été retirée en
catastrophe la semaine dernière
Je crois qu'il y a des pressions.
De qui ?
Je sais pas.
On peut imaginer de qui ?
Je sais pas. Je crois qu'il y a Je crois
qu'il y a des Je crois qu'il crois qu'il
y a des collaborateurs. Je crois qu'il y
a des carrières à faire. Je crois je
sais pas mais enfin je pense qu'il y a
des Je pense qu'il y a des pressions.
Ça veut dire quoi des carrières à faire
?
Je sais pas. Je pense qu'il y a des
pressions. Je je pense qu'il y a des
Vous savez vous savez comment ça se
passe. Vous travaillez dans les
hôpitaux, c'est la fonction publique.
C'est c'est compliqué. ça devient quand
même très politique maintenant quand
vous avez vous avez un ministre qui
empêche l'hydroxychloroquine. Donc vous
pouvez pas vous pouvez pas utiliser
hydroxy chloroquine puisque le décret
vous empêche de de prescrire l'hydroxy
chloroquin dans les cas qui ne sont pas
graves.
D'après ce que j'ai compris,
d'après ce que j'ai compris, certains
ont quand même dans les hôpitaux, y
compris de tous les hôpitaux de la PHP,
dans tous les hôpitaux de la PHP, enfin
la plupart des hôpitaux de la PHP, il y
a des médecins qui ont donné des requin
à des gens qui étaient pas graves.
Donc c'est quand le décret les
ministres, donc ça c'est faire attention
que vous êtes de la fonction publique.
Donc il vaut mieux quand même ne pas
exister. Bah voilà ce que c'est comme ça
que je l'ai compris. Maintenant voilà ça
c'est pas moi, c'est pas moi le dire.
Quel volume euh quel volume financier
pour l'IU
c'est combien d'investissement de départ
? Euh est-ce que le
crois c'est 300 35 je crois que c'est du
de 300 350 millions je crois en
l'ensemble.
C'est le conseiller d'administration qui
fixe le salaire de Didier Raou.
Non je pense que Didier Raou est
professeur d'université PUPH
c'est tout.
Combien ça gagne ?
Comment
combien ça gagne ? Un PUH doit gagner à
peu près aux alentours de 4 8000 € à peu
près.
Un Philippe Doublasi gagne combien ?
Alors moi je n'ai pas euh moi maintenant
je malheureusement mon euh je suis à la
je rentre à la retraite maintenant de
cette donc moi j'avais j'avais arrêté ma
valence hospitalière
et euh je donnais des cours. Je donne
encore des cours d'ailleurs rare cours
euh en première année de médecine de
santé publique. J'y tiens beaucoup. Euh
c'est h j'ai fait euh j'ai deux filles,
l'un à Bicha et l'autre à Villemain. Euh
je donne des cours chaque année aux
premières années de médecine euh sur la
santé publique. Euh je leur explique ce
que c'est la spécialité Renn
mais je suis à la retraite maintenant.
Et donc un un jeune retraité comme vous,
il gagne combien ? Alors moi c'est la la
retraite d'un professeur enfin pour moi
en tout cas ça entre 350
comme ça quoi.
Retraite de ministre.
Alors l'arrête date de ministre, je l'ai
pas. figurez-vous que euh ça doit être
quelque chose comme
3005 aussi à peu près.
Je je vous le dirai de manière exacte si
vous voulez parce que
une expert comptable
c'est parce que oui c'est non c'est moi
c'est pas ça c'est que j'ai une expert
comptable mais j'ai pas fait valoir
parce que comme j'avais encore une
valence universitaire je on m'a expliqué
que je pouvais perdre un peu si je
faisais valoir tous mes droits d'ancien
élu local ministre et cetera donc
l'expert comptable ça nous occupé mais
je pourrais si je suis à votre
disposition pour donner ma fille ma ma
fiche de retraite.
Vous avez un gros patrimoine ?
Non.
Vous avez investi dans des boîtes ?
J'ai investi dans dans J'ai investi dans
Alors, j'ai investi dans aucune boîte,
sauf qu'on m'a donné 1 % une fois
gratuitement d'une boîte. Voilà.
Et ça arrive souvent qu'on vous donne
des pourcents comme ça.
Jamais, on me l'a donné, on m'a donné 1
% pour une boîte qui vaut zéro. Donc euh
aujourd'hui, enfin je pense qu'elle vaut
zéro aujourd'hui. Donc euh je pense pas
qu'on fait un cadeau.
Est-ce que vous pensez avoir des
casseroles en tant comme politique ?
Non, je n'ai euh je n'ai pas de euh je
non je je peut-être que c'est le plus
grand luxe de ma vie, c'est de dormir
tranquillement.
C'est quand quand on a préparé cette
émission, on a contacté vos détracteurs
et on nous a dit d'où te blas les
laboratoires serviers, tu Google, tu
trouves.
Ah oui,
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
cette histoire ?
Oui, alors ça je peux vous les expliquer
très très bien. Laboratoire Servier
c'est des odo trois choses. La première
c'est que lorsque j'étais chef de
clinique,
je devais avoir quoi ? 28 ans, je sais
pas oui. C'est ça. 27 28 ans. Euh,
c'est beau.
Oui, oui, merci. Euh
mis, j'ai été choisi parmi les 30 chefs
de clinique en France qui ont fait
partie d'un groupe qui qui et et et le
porteur servi a décidé de nous offrir
une conférence par an par un professeur.
Voilà. Et donc avec le voyage
payé à Paris. Est-ce que vous avez été
poursuivi par la justice ?
Non, jamais. Non non non mais ça c'est
que je dis c'est totalement légal. Je
veux dire c'est c'est
la justice. Ça c'est c'est voilà le
rapport que j'ai eu servier. Donc je
crois que j'ai fait ça 2 ans ou 3 ans.
J'ai eu trois conférences qui ont été
données par des gens extraordinaires
et j'ai jamais eu j'ai jamais eu
d'argent, ils m'ont jamais rien payé et
cetera. Donc ça c'est la première chose.
C'est mais c'est mais c'est ressorti ça.
Il y a des gens qui ont ça peut sortir
sur Google. Moi très bien. La deuxième
chose c'est que euh il se trouve que
monsieur Servier euh donc a eu affaires
médiator. Moi, j'ai eu aucun rapport
avec j'ai jamais eu de discussion ni
d'argent de près ou de loin avec les
laboratoires serviers.
Pas du tout. Enfin, j'ai jamais
travaillé pour eux, j'ai jamais fait de
conférences pour eux. que j'ai jamais
été rémunéré pour eux. J'ai pas fait
d'études cliniques pour des pour des
médicaments serviers. Ça m'est jamais
arrivé.
Euh mais ce qui était marqué, c'est que
lorsqu'il y a eu des perquisitions dans
le bureau de monsieur Servier, il
mettait des notes à tout le monde. Il
disait "Mais monsieur Devas est très
bien ou c'est un ami, je sais pas
quelque chose comme ça." Et donc c'était
c'est sorti de la presse ça en disant
"Mais pourquoi il dit ça ?" Et donc,
j'ai été amené à m'expliquer sur ça au
monde de la grande enquête servier et
d'ailleurs on m'a dit "Mais monsieur,
vas-y très bien, parfait, tout le monde
a compris que c'était pour rien quoi. Ni
de près ni de loin, j'étais dans cette
affaire du médiator."
Euh,
je suis en train de lire les questions
les questions sur notre forme de
discussion où les gens peuvent nous
envoyer des questions. Et là, je viens
de voir deux deux des dernières
questions qui viennent d'être d'être
posées. Alors, c'est peut-être de la
diffamation, méfiez-vous. Si je pose
cette question là,
il y a quelqu'un qui nous marque
c'est pas une casserole la pédophilie.
Ça ça c'est la diffamation,
c'est ça ? Oui, ça c'est ça veut dire
que si il y a ça, ça veut dire qu'il
faut me donner, si vous me permettez,
euh l'adresse email de cette personne et
elle aura demain euh un avocat qui en
pénal euh ira le chercher
personnellement
euh parce que ça c'est quelque chose que
je ne laisserai jamais passer de ma vie.
Euh je suis médecin en plus et donc vous
comprenez donc ça c'est vous allez me le
donner s'il vous plaît hein monsieur. Je
vous le demande parce que sinon je
quitterai tout de suite cette émission.
Vous me le donnerez ?
Je Si vous arrivez à trouver leur IP, je
vous laisserai avoir accès à ce qu'on
peut vous donner.
Très bien.
Euh une question.
Ah non, vous m'avez dit à ce que vous
pourrez me donner. Moi, je veux vraiment
avoir ça, c'est des je vais jusqu'au
bout là ce genre de chose. Je ne
laisserai jamais quelqu'un. Euh
pourquoi ? Pourquoi on dit ça ? Pourquoi
il y a certains qui disent ça ? Non,
parce que ça, pourquoi on dit de vous,
pourquoi on le dit de moi ? Je ne sais
pas. Mais ça, je trouve ça euh terrible
parce que quelqu'un puisse dire ça,
c'est immédiatement le pénal. Et
j'espère
plus que ça que que ça sera la
condamnation la plus dure possible. Je
ne laisserai jamais personne dire ça.
Jamais.
Revenons à nos histoires de l'IU.
Comment vous pensez qu'on va pouvoir se
sortir de cette chiant entre le
une population qui est en train de se
scinder en deux équipe qui s'invective à
longueur de journée ? Comment on va
pouvoir sortir de cette chien
entre l'Hu et
et et toutes ces attaques de ils font
des études qui ne fonctionne pas, il se
critique, il compare les carottes avec
des patates. La seule solution aurait
été de faire une étude qui soit
prospective si vous voulez en double
aveugle, randomisé
et on peut expliquer à nos internautes
ce que c'est. C'est-à-dire que on
définit au départ les critères
d'inclusion et les critères d'exclusion
au départ. Euh et donc euh par exemple,
on veut tant d'hypertendus,
tant d'obèses, tant de jeunes, tant de
vieux et donc ce qu'on a fait, on fait
des apparients. On a dans les deux
groupes et en général le hasard fait
très bien les choses. On le fait au
hasard. C'est le même nombre de femmes,
le même nombre d'hommes, le même nombre
de gens entre 30 et 40 ans, le même
nombre de gens entre 40 et 50 ans.
Point, on décide ça. Tant d'hypertendu,
tant d'obèse ou alors pas d'obèse, pas
d'hypertendu, pas de cigarette ou alors
oui des fumeurs. Mais combien ? 20 % 20
%. Il y a qu'un truc qui qui change,
c'est le traitement. Et donc là ça, oui,
ce jour-là, on pourra répondre. Tant
qu'on aura pas fait ça, on répondra pas.
Euh je regardais un débat hier soir euh
entre les pours et les contres et il y
avait un médecin généraliste de terrain
qui disait quand même euh
l'hydrochloroxyquine euh ça peut être
bien contre les orages cyochiniques et
on va se priver
ça c'est le grand sujet c'est que c'est
une maladie on revient à ce que on vient
de dire tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire
qu'on ne la connaît pas et que
aujourd'hui il y a toute une parce que
voilà ce qu'on a cru au début c'est que
le virus multiplie se multiplie se
multiplie se multiplie c'est la phase
virale 07e jour et c'est là où on joue
donc dans hydroxy on met et on prescrit
hydroxychloroquine hydromicine chez Raou
pendant le début le plus tôt possible
pour diminuer la charge virale et
ensuite on pensait que la charge virale
diminuait certains ont commencé à dire
il y a plusieurs semaines détrompé z
vous
g virales très élevées à la fin
et et donc et d'autre part vous avez un
orage cyochinique et l'hydroxychloroine
elle marche comment ? Elle marche par
une partie immunitaire. C'est la raison
pour laquelle on la donne au lupus et au
poulet rumatoïdes
et elle a aussi d'autres actions euh et
donc il y a des
des gens qui ont pensé que elle pourrait
être extrêmement utile à ce momentlà
dans le reste cyochinique.
Il semble que ce soit vrai mais enfin
bon là aussi c'est tout le problème
c'est
vous pouvez parler beaucoup de
physiologie et de physiopathologie
et ensuite devant le malade comme vous
disiez tout à l'heure la guerre vous
êtes devant le malade quand vous êtes
devant le malade un jour dans votre vie
que vous êtes médecin et que vous voyez
la personne devant vous avec ses
constantes en réanimation euh là c'est
autre chose. Une question pour le
l'ancien ministre de la santé et pour le
cardiologue, pour le TBIB. Qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de l'utilisation du cannabis
euh euh pour ces vertus euh euh
médicamenteuses
thérapeutique ?
Thérapeutique. Merci.
Oui. Moi, je suis pour
pour
Oui, bien sûr. Le cannabis
thérapeutique, c'est important. Euh
c'est en déouloureux, c'est
le cannabis thérapeutique. Je suis pour
pour bien sûr.
Comment vous voyez ça ? encadré comment
par l'État ?
Ah bah c'est encadré si
c'est c'est une cannabis à but
thérapeutique. C'est c'est donc c'est en
déjà fumé en joint.
Non alors j'ai passé pour un débile
mental.
Pourquoi ?
Mais non c'est vous êtes pas vous allez
passer pour un débile mental. Voilà.
Mais voilà donc
jamais
sûr. Donc donc vous voyez la la la tête
que vous faites. Ah je fais aucune tête.
Vous avez un masque, c'est pour ça que
je
Est-ce qu'on peut parler de l'euthanasie
?
Oui.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
l'euthanasie ?
Ah
alors moi j'ai un très une grande
admiration pour Jean Leonetti.
pas parce qu'il est cardiologue comme
moi, parce que c'est un humaniste.
Je pense que la loi, je serai ministre
aujourd'hui, je ne la toucherai pas.
Euh
j'ai comme euh
médecin comme tout le monde, j'ai j'ai
suivi des patients qui étaient
cancéreux, qui avaient des cancers du
poumon et qui avait des métastases
osseuses.
Ouais. qui font très mal.
Et comme tout le monde,
j'ai donné de la morphine
et comme tout le monde
euh à partir d'un certain nombre de
d'ampoules de morphine, vous avez le
centre
un hyperbolus
ici qui euh
vous fait arrêter de de respirer au
fond.
Donc c'est tout un équilibre. Là, vous
êtes en train de me dire que vous avez
euthanasié.
Non, j'ai pas dit ça. Je dis que tout
médecin a ce problème un jour dans la
vie.
Tout médecin a un jour un J'ai pas dit
ça. J'ai dit un jour tout médecin a ce
problème là. c'est que vous avez devant
vous un homme, une femme qui souffre,
dont on sait que c'est fini, qui a très
très très très mal et que vous pouvez
l'aider en lui donnant de la morphine,
mais
vous pouvez aussi l'aider en faisant ce
que l'on appelle des soins palliatifs.
Et moi, je suis un grand partisan du
soin palliatif.
Donc c'est deux choses différentes.
Donc le palliatif quand j'ai été
ministre, j'ai essayé d'en augmenter
d'en augmenter d'en augmenter. Je l'ai
fait mais pas suffisamment que j'aurais
aimé. J'ai pas eu le budget pour ça.
Mais en effet, le président Chirak
m'aidait à avoir ses budgets. Mais c'est
pas lui non plus qui pouvait le faire.
Enfin, il aurait pu le faire mais il m'a
aidé au maximum.
Mais c'est un rapport de conscience que
je voulais vous dire, c'est que c'est un
rapport de conscience terrible entre
médecin et son malade.
C'est ça soigner.
C'est ça soigner. C'est soigner, c'est
un rapport de vous avez deux sortes de
médecines au fond. Vous avez la
médecine, c dont on parle, c'est-à-dire
un homme, un homme ou une femme, peu
importe, un rapport, un colloque
singulier à deux.
Personne ne remplacera ça. C'est c'est
extraordinaire quoi. C'est c'est
vraiment le métier meilleur plus beau
métier du monde. Tuas un rapport de
confiance de la part du malade, de
conscience de la part du médecin. Vous
devez et si si vous devez pas dormir
pendant 3 jours, dormirez pas pendant 3
jours. De toute façon, il y a que ça qui
compte.
Mais
là, il y a un moment où quand la machine
quand vous voyez que c'est fini, vous
avez un un devoir de parler parce que
vous connaissez très bien votre malade
et vous parlez au fond avec lui au fond
et souvent il vous dit des choses qui
qui ne dira à personne d'autre au fond.
Parfois ça peut arriver.
Le médecin est assisté après ça ?
Non, pas du tout.
et et donc fait au cas de mon temps
parce que je ne pratique pas
et euh et donc euh voilà, ça c'est
compliqué de légiférer là-dedans, c'est
compliqué d'aller envoyer de la loi
dedans. Je je comprends très bien qu'il
y a des députés extraordinaires qui
pourront en parler, qui qui auront tout
toutes les possibilités d'en parler, la
liberté, la truc, je sais mais c'est
compliqué pour moi. On est allé au
maximum avec la loi léonetti, on ne peut
pas aller plus loin. Je vais beaucoup
choquer évidemment ceux qui sont pour
l'euthanasie parce que je comprends ce
qu'il y a derrière ce qu'ils pensent
eux. C'est la liberté.
C'est la liberté de ne plus souffrir, la
liberté de partir, liberté et cetera.
Et en même temps, j'ai tellement vu de
gens dans ma vie parce que je suis
cardiologue et pas cancérologue.
J'ai tellement vu de gens qui allaient
mourir et qui 2 ans après allaient
tellement bien et tellement heureux de
vivre que j'ai évidemment c'est facile
de dire ça et ceux qui m'écoutent vont
dire ça mais une pirhouette c'est pas
une pirouette je l'ai vécu et cela il
pouvaient peut-être me dire ils me l'ont
pas dit c'est vrai mais ils auraient pu
me le dire maintenant ça suffit on en
peut plus là je respire plus je n'y
arrive plus des types qui a fait des
fonctions ventricurs gauche à à 45 %
quoi qui qui était sous in
éjection ventriculaire gauche
éjection ventriculaire gauche qui qui en
pouvait plus qui qui était qui faisait
des odèmes du poumon euh debout quoi
et à faire assis et donc si vous voulez
c'est
une une question extrêmement difficile.
Je n'ai pas la certitude moi en tout cas
de la réponse
mais quand même je pense qu'on était la
loi léonetti c'est bien. Voilà.
Bon pour être un peu plus léger parce
que c'est quand même un sujet lourd. Le
cannabis récréatif pour le ministère de
la santé qu'est-ce qu'il en pense ?
Non le ministère oui fait le cannabis
quoi. Vou la libéralisation du cannabis
c'est ça dont vous parlez. Ouai.
Alors là, c'est extrêmement compliqué
parce que j'ai toujours été contre. Mais
euh
pourquoi ?
Non, j'ai toujours été contre parce que
parce que je je sais je sais très bien
euh tout ce qui se passe. Euh enf vous
le savez aussi très bien que moi que euh
je rien
j'étais maire de Toulouse donc j'ai j'ai
je suis arrivé un jour, ils m'ont fait
faire un truc assez extraordinaire. On
on a fait on a fait trois commandants de
bord d'Airbus
qui ont 15 ans hein de de pratique. Euh
et on leur a fait euh voler sur Vous
savez qu'aujourd'hui la première fois
que un commandant de bord vole sur un
avion, il vole pas du tout. C'est la
première fois de sa vie qu'il vole sur
un vrai avion. Enfin avant il a volé sur
un sur un
sur un petit avion. Non, sur
un simulateur
au simulateur. Et le simulateur est fait
de manière tellement exceptionnelle
aujourd'hui que il vole vraiment dans
l'avion. Donc la première fois où il y a
des passagers au fond, c'est la première
fois qu'il prend l'avion euh cet
avion-là. Et donc euh je crois que c'est
un peu ça. J'exagère peut-être un peu
mais c'est un peu ça. Donc le simulateur
est très bien fait. Et donc ce
simulateur euh il
ce simulateur
[Musique]
ils prennent l'avion comme ça, il dit
voilà on est au Toulouse, tu nous amènes
à à Birit, tu nous ramènes.
Alors il ils font ça, ils partent, ils
partent et puis euh ils reviennent, il
remet parfait l'avion. Impeccable. Ils
font fumer deux cigarettes,
ils laissent passer font rire,
hein,
des cigarettes qui font rire.
Des cigarettes qui font rire. Et ensuite
euh 2h après ou 1 heure après, je sais
pas combien, je veux pas dire de
bêtises, mais enfin x temps après, ils
refont mais ils se sont ils se sont ils
se sont ils sont pas crachés. fait c'est
pire que ça. Ils ils ont ils ont posé
l'avion à 30 m de là où ils devaient
poser. Donc donc qu'on me fasse pas
croire à moi en tout cas qu'il n'y a pas
d'effet. Mais c'est vrai aussi sur
l'alcool.
C'est vrai aussi sur l'alcool. C'est
c'est vrai. Donc c'est c'est extrêmement
compliqué et moi je voilà ça me pose pas
de problème en effet
sur l'alcool et ça m'empose là-dessus.
Donc c'est pas tout à fait honnête aussi
ce que je raconte mais quand même je me
dis que et puis j'ai peur aussi du
départ. Alors après, il y a l'avantage,
c'est que les
horribles personnes qui font du
trafic avec ça, bien évidemment, vous
les supprimez dès l'instant où vous
l'avez.
Donc ce qu'a fait le premier ministre du
Canada au fond, il a arrêté une mafia et
il a gagné beaucoup d'argent. euh en
même temps dans son état puisque vous
gagnez autant un d'argent sinon plus
d'argent en vendant du
qui a pris un contrepied à la guerre
contre la drogue. C'est ça.
C'est ça. Et quelque part il a il a fait
un contrepied à la lutte contre la
drogue. C'est la raison pour laquelle je
n'ai pas de certitude. C'est la raison
pour laquelle c'est quelque chose qui
j'ai évolué dans la mesure où avant
j'étais très contre. Aujourd'hui, je
suis ouvert à une discussion sur la
société.
Ça fait tellement de mal à nos banlieux.
Ça fait tellement de mal en tant que
ancien mère de Toulouse, j'ai vu des
gosses faire le gay à 11 ans pour dire
aux plus vieux que les autres
arrivaient, revenir avec des poches
plein de billets de 500.
C'est c'est affreux. Enfin bon, c'est
c'est tout ça est horrible. Donc il faut
le casser à un moment donné. C'est
peut-être une occasion de le casser. Je
ne sais pas. quand vous étiez euh dans
un gouvernement,
est-ce que vous avez rencontré des
politiques, des professionnels de la
politique qui était euh sous complément
un petit peu anabolisant ? Est-ce qu'il
prenait des choses ou des choses comme
ça ?
Moi, ça m'est jamais arrivé.
Jamais arrivé.
J'ai jamais vu quelqu'un en face de moi
faire de la politique en prenant des des
de la coque ou ça m'est jamais arrivé.
Si
il y a pas des bruits de couloir ? des
bruits de couloir, il y en a beaucoup.
Des des bruits de couloir, il y en a
beaucoup beaucoup. Mais c'est des choses
qui que je n'ai jamais vu.
Est-ce que vous voyez un sujet qu'on a
pas abordé, que vous voulez aborder avec
nous ?
Oui. Euh aborder ma vie que j'ai que
j'ai eu en 2007 lorsque en fait j'aurais
aimé vouloir j'aurais aimé continuer la
vie politique au gouvernement. J'avais
fait 8 9 ans comme ministre. Donc
j'avais fait beaucoup hein. C'est vrai.
Je suis un franc gâté. euh pour ça, mais
j'aurais aimé continuer. Bon, je n'ai
pas été pris dans le gouvernement et euh
j'ai eu la chance d'être choisi comme
secrétaire général adjoint des Nations-
Unies, pas du tout par la France parce
que la France n'était pas au courant,
mais par Ben Kimoun avec lequel j'avais
des relations. C'était un ancien
ministre d'affaires étrangères de Corée
du Sud quand j'étais ministre d'affaires
étrangères français et il m'a choisi.
Bon, c'est un grand titre ronflant.
Secrétaire général adjoint des Nations-
Unies, il y en a 50 ou 60 70. Vous
gagnez 1 dollar an que vous ne n'êtes
pas obligé de déclarer et vous n'avez
pas d'administration. Donc je ne me fais
pas passer pour le numéro 2 de l'ONU. Ce
n'est pas vrai. Je n'avais pas
d'administration. Par contre, ce que
j'ai fait, c'est que j'en ai profité
pour euh continuer ce que j'avais créé
euh à à lorsque j'étais mise affaires
étrangères qui s'appelle United. U N I T
A I D. Et cette et cette chose c'est une
chose importante que nous avons fait
avec le président Chirak grâce au
président Chirak,
c'est l'idée de dire euh il faut à tout
prix qu'on aide les gens pauvres qui ont
le sid la tuberculose, le paludisme dans
les
mort ça parent dans le monde
la totalité des trois
beaucoup euh pas vous dire come ça fait
les trois mais ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que un enfant du paludisme meurt
un enfant meurt du paludisme 2 minutes
en période humide
Donc voyez les différences en période de
mousson. Donc vous voyez la différence
qu'il y a entre le palu et le Covid. Ça
vous donne une rapide.
Donc et donc nous avons demandé 1 € par
billet d'avion à tous les voyageurs qui
prennent l'avion. Donc on l'a fait dans
une dizaine de pays, h pays. C'est à la
fois un échec et un succès. Un échec
parce qu'il y a très peu de pays qui ont
accepté de le faire et c'est un succès
parce que nous avons sur les 8 ou 10
pays, je ne sais plus qui l'ont fait,
euh nous avons pu récolter plus de 4
milliards de dollars euh en l'espace de
essentiellement français d'ailleurs euh
en l'espace de 10 ans ou 11 ans. Avec
cet argent, nous avons fait plusieurs
choses. Premièrement, nous avons fait
d'abord, il faut savoir que il y a des
articles qui disent et des modélisations
qui disent c'est pas les miennes, c'est
elles sont internationales qui montrent
que United, je l'ai donc fondé et je
l'ai présidé pendant 10 ans. Donc c'est
pour ça que je je suis très sensible à
ça. Et cette cette United, c'est une un
succès de la diplomatie française.
Donc son conseil d'administration est
fait de la France, du Royaume-Uni, de la
Norvège, de l'Union africaine, du
Brésil, du Chili.
de la fondation Gites et des ONG.
Je t'ai présidé pendant 10 ans et
aujourd'hui on dit que grosso modo 100
millions de personnes profitent
bénéficient des innovations d'unit par
an. Donc c'est beaucoup.
Nous faisons plusieurs choses. La
première, c'est les innovations
thérapeutiques. Par exemple, lorsque
nous avons nous sommes arrivés en 2007,
nous avons commencé en 2007, nous sommes
aperçus que il n'y avait pas d'enfants
qui étaient soignés par des médicaments
contre le sida. Ça existait pas. Les les
médicaments pédiatriques contre le sida
n'existaient pas. Alors, on a dit "Mais
pourquoi ça n'existe pas ?" "Mais parce
qu'il y en a pas." On n a pas d'enfants
qui ont le sida. Mais comment ça il y a
pas d'enfants qui ont le sida ? Oui, il
y a beaucoup d'enfants qui non monsieur,
il y a pas d'enfant. Euh non, il y en a
pas dans les pays. Alors, c'est vrai que
dans les pays riches, il n'y a pas
d'enfants qui ont le sida. Pourquoi ?
Parce que les femmes enceintes qui sont
achivées positives, il y en a beaucoup
mais elles prennent les trithérapies. Et
avec une trithérapie, c'est curieux
d'ailleurs parce que dans le
cordonbilical passe le virus mais le
virus n'infecte pas l'enfant. Donc
l'enfant nî sans virus. Et donc on dit
mais pourquoi voulez-vous que l'on mette
des millions à développer des
médicaments pour les enfants alors que
il n'y a pas d'enfants atteint de sida ?
Dit mais parce que il y en a je sais pas
combien 1000 qui qui naissent tous les
jours dans le monde simplement ils sont
en Afrique ou en Asie du Sud-Est. Et
donc nous avons
fait fabriquer, nous avons avec l'argent
des gens qui prennent l'avion 1 € par
billet d'avion, nous avons développé les
premiers médicaments, les seuls
d'ailleurs médicaments pédiatriques
contre le sida. Et pendant les quatre
premières années entre 2007 et 2011, 8
enfants sur 10 qui étaient soignés
contre le sida étaient soigné grâce à
United. Et puis ensuite c'est parti au
fond mondial et maintenant pratiquement
tous les enfants qui sont soignés contre
le sida le sont grâce à United. Enfin
bon, c'est intéressant. Euh euh comme
deuxième innovation thérapeutique que
nous avons faite, c'est récente
celle-là. Euh c'est contre le paludisme.
En fait, on s'est aperçu que en donnant
uniquement quatre doses quatre doses euh
de médicament euh à des enfants par mois
uniquement pendant les 4 ou 5 mois de
mousson,
on diminue de 20 millions par an le
nombre de cas de palu.
Donc United avec d'autres hein, mais
enfin c'est United qui a créé ça quand
même qui a été moteur dans ça en United
en avec en dosant en donnant quatre
doses à des enfants euh africains euh de
moins de 5 ans ou de 10 ans, je me plus
les enfants de moins de 10 ans euh
pendant la mousson et bien vous évitez
25 millions de cas de palu. Il faut
savoir que je le redis un enfant meurt
toutes les 2 minutes, un peu plus d'un
enfant. meurt toutes les 2 minutes du
palu euh pendant la mousse et même un
peu après.
J'ai On va passer. Vous voulez rajouter
quelque chose ?
Non non mais c'est pas grave mais je
pourrais dire plein de choses mais c'est
important quand même. United c'est c'est
quelque chose c'est ma vie au fond hein.
Donc
et pourquoi personne l'avait fait avant
? Non, et puis non seulement personne ne
l'a fait avant, mais surtout personne ne
le sait euh parce que ça n'intéresse
personne. Euh le type qui vient de dire
des des des horreurs là sur moi, euh il
sait même pas euh ce que j'ai fait dans
ma vie sur les enfants de ne pas. On est
la la première organisation au monde sur
la tuberculose de l'enfant. Il le sait
pas. il sait pas que cette vie est
passée au service des des enfants les
plus pauvres ou des ou des adultes
d'ailleurs les plus pauvres de ce de ce
pays parce que pour eux la politique
c'est un truc dégueulasse avec des trucs
épouvantables et cetera alors que la
politique elle peut être noble.
Question d'internet : peut-il nous
parler de la déconnexion du monde
politique dont il a parlé ? Je je lis la
la question textuellement.
En fait, j'ai pas trop parlé de la
téconnexion. Je peux en parler mais j'ai
pas parlé trop de la déconnexion. Je
pense il se pense pas. Euh
c'est en fait la vie politique, ce qui
est vrai, c'est que la vie politique
devrait avoir un temps au fond. Un homme
politique devrait faire de la un homme
une femme politique devrait faire de la
de la politique un temps. C'est c'est
vrai aux États-Unis
combien de temps ?
Une quinzaine d'années maximum. Je veux
dire, vous voyez parce que
euh c'est vrai que être député à à 25
ans et être ensuite ministre, secrétaire
d'État puis sénateur jusqu'à 85 ans,
c'est vrai que c'est pas c'est pas
obligatoirement bon ou être ministre
trop longtemps, c'est pas trop bon non
plus. Ce qui m'était arrivé d'ailleurs,
au bout d'un moment, vous perdez un peu.
Mais je pense que en tout cas la
question qui est posée est intéressante.
Je vais y répondre. euh sur est-ce qu'il
faut que les ministres ne soient pas ma
Non mais c'est intéressant parce que
tout le monde pense que il faut pas que
les ministres soit maire et on peut j'ai
même entendu récemment un grand
responsable de l'éthique politique qui
est de rosière enfin qui un type très
très sérieux un ancien député qui
s'occupe d'éthique en politique et qui a
fait beaucoup d'ailleurs dans sa vie
pour ça dire qu'il y a des conflits
d'intérêt au fond entre le maire et
ministre, ce qui est vrai. Euh mais en
même temps, si vous avez que des
politiciens,
politiciens j'aime pas ce mot, des
hommes politiques, des femmes ou des
responsables politiques, des
responsables politiques qui sont
complètement coupés, si vous faites une
si vous faites demain une législative
législative à la proportionnelle
intégrale,
si vous faites unection législative la
proportionnelle intégrale, ce quand même
normal vis-à-vis de l'extrême gauche et
vis-à-vis de l'extrême droite. Et bon,
moi je suis contre extrême droite, mais
enfin il faut bien reconnaître que ils
sont mal représentés à l'assemblée. Mais
si vous faites une une proportionnelle
intégrale d'extrême en France,
vous allez avoir des gens dont le métier
va être d'être dans ces listes. Mais ils
sont jamais allés ces gens dans une
enfin, ils vont dans leur boulangerie.
Oui, c'est sûr. Mais enfin, ils sont pas
au contact de la vraie vie. Moi, je me
suis fait engueuler toute ma vie.
J'étais 20 ans maire, je me suis fait
engueuler 20 ans et vous faites
engueuler euh c'est souvent pas sympa,
mais c'est comme ça. Souvent on vous dit
merci monsieur le maire, mais le plus
souvent on vous dit le trou là, ça fait
6 mois qu'on vous dit qu'il est qu'il
est qu'il est devant la la la le
magasin. Ça fait 6 mois qu'il est
toujours là et le lampadaire, il est
toujours cassé. Bon voilà. Donc si vous
enlevez donc la déconnexion pour
répondre à l'internaute déconnexion de
l'homme politique, il doit pour lutter
contre la déconnexion de l'homme
politique un il faut que la personne qui
arrive au plus haut niveau sache ce que
c'est que la vraie vie
et pour qu'il sache aussi ce qui est la
vraie vie c'est que de temps en temps,
il faut qu'il y revienne.
Donc je crois que c'est ça la réponse.
C'est et ça notre constitution devrait
réfléchir. Alors Nicolas Sarkozy a
limité à deux le
bon je sais pas si c'est une bonne chose
d'ailleurs. Enfin bon, il a limité à
deux les mandats présidentiels qui fait
10 ans. Mais il faut trouver des
solutions de respiration et puis aussi
c'est pas normal que ce soit toujours
les mêmes qu'il soient députés ou
sénateur. C'est vrai que moi j'ai pu
faire de la politique parce que je suis
professeur de médecine et que si j'étais
battu, ben je peux revenir demain matin
à la fonction publique. Ce qui m'est
arrivé d'ailleurs, dès que j'ai été
battu, dès que j'ai pu été au au
gouvernement, j'ai pu revenir. Euh
j'avais d'ailleurs, je le dis ici, euh
j'aurais pu très bien euh être les deux
ministres députés euh à l'époque députés
européens et professeurs de médecine. Il
y avait beaucoup de gens qui étaient
députés européens, professeurs de
médecine et qui cumulaient les deux
salaires. Euh et je tiens à dire que
j'ai toujours refusé ça euh et beaucoup
de mes collègues ne le faisaient pas.
C'est combien le salaire d'un député
européen ?
Plus de 10000 €.
Net.
Oui. Oui.
Je pense que c'est
Et euh je reviens je reviens sur Didier
Raou. Quand Didier Raou disait
mais ouais je sais pas je sais pas
combien vaut enfin d'ailleurs aux
internautes
c'est en France c'est ça non ? Non non
non, je sais pas si c'est net, je sais
pas combien, je sais pas s'ils peuvent
s'ils peuvent cumuler des primes, je
sais pas. Enfin, c'est c'est quand même
très confortable.
Je résume trivialement ce qu'on va faire
monter là. Quand Didier Raou disait que
il y avait plus il y aurait plus
d'accidents de trottinette que de
coronavirus en France, que c'était que
en Chine que ça tué trois Chinois que en
France on a
c'était pas vrai.
C'était pas vrai. H mais
il a dit il a reconnu. C'est comme ça.
Ça gêne pas maintenant à ça gêne pas
l'opinion publique à à pouvoir se faire
une opinion tout ça qu'au départ la fin
Bien sûr bien sûr
bien sûr. Mais ça bien évidemment on est
tous par rapport et je crois qu'il faut
pas qu'on pas je crois je crois qu'il
faut pas confondre les grandes
difficultés dans ce débat là qui devient
quand même presque une crise de ner
nationale.
C'est que il faut il faut vraiment
remettre quand même la médecine au cœur
de ce de ce de de ce de ce sujet.
Comment on fait ?
Et ben, je crois que dans ce que vous
avez dit tout à l'heure, par exemple en
disant Did Did Rault, il a il a fait
comme un médecin de guerre au départ.
C'est c'est c'est ça peut intéresser
quand même les gens qui nous écoutent
pour comprendre.
Médecine de guerre c'est une discipline
hein.
Oui. Médecine de guerre quand vous êtes
vous êtes médecin inftiologue que vous
voyez arriver des milliers de types qui
sont disponibles qui insuffisant
respiratoire et qui partent pour
certains partent en ré à l'âge de 30
ans. Croyez-moi, c'est une discipline
aussi. Donc je veux dire c'est c'est
comme les médecines de guerre. C'estàd
que il faut moi quand je enfin bon pas
parler de moi mais je veux dire il y a
des moments c'est dur quand vous avez le
flot de malade devant vous et que vous
devez les traiter donc vous avez aidé
quand vous avez dit ça tout à l'heure.
Euh deuxièmement ça donc c'est la
médecine il faut il faut revenir à ça.
Deuxièmement il faut dire que si on veut
savoir définitivement il faut un essai
clinique randomisé. tant qu'on l'aura
pas, on ne pourra pas le dire sur les
deux, hydroxychloroquine et asromicine
pour justement les effets cardiologiques
dont vous avez parlé respectif aux deux.
Euh et puis ensuite, il faut sortir de
là la la personnalité
du médecin.
Ça vous ça vous est arrivé d'avoir des
médecins avec qui vous entendez et des
médecins avec qui vous entendez pas ?
Bon voilà, mais parfois ce que avec qui
vous entendez pas, parfois croyez-moi,
c'est certains chirurgiens que je
connais qui sont très très bons s sont
sur le plan humain mais enfin parfois je
me ferai opérer par je me Non non non,
j'ai pas dit ça c'est mais je me ferai
opérer par eux quand même vous voyez
même s'il m'engueulent la salle
d'attente.
Un sal con et un bon chirurgien.
Comment
on peut être un sal con et un bon
chirurgien ?
On peut être un salon et bon chirurgien.
C'est ça exactement. Je pense
ça va pas souvent de perdre de temps en
temps. Non
non non non, ça c'est pas vrai. Mais
mais mais je veux dire par là que voilà,
c'est compliqué. C'est la vie est
compliquée, les hommes sont compliqués.
Trois vitesses en France.
Non, ce que je crois c'est que je l'ai
dit l'autre jour, je pense que le Séure,
il ne faut pas que ce soit une occasion
manquée. Je crois que le Séure certes,
il faut augmenter
le salaire des infirmières, des
paramédicaux et de certains proté
hospitaliers. Ça c'est vrai. Nous sommes
22e rang des 33 de l'OCDE. Une
infirmière gagne 2000
3 300
au début de carrière, ils sont à 1500
balles ou un truc comme ça. 159.
D'accord. Mais une infirmière, c'est à
peu près 2405 € net. Euh 2405 € net. Euh
c'est l'adresse 2016. Voyez une une une
aide soignante, c'est 1780 € net.
mensuel, c'est pas acceptable. Bon, ça
d'accord, mais une fois que vous avez
dit ça, bon très bien, euh vous la paix
euh social, espérons euh les
rémunérations vont monter, il le faut.
Le respect, il le faut. Mais il faut se
poser des questions.
La première, la vôtre. Comme comme en
1958, la réforme de Debré de Robert
Debré sous le général de Gaul. La
qualité des soins, c'est ça votre
question ? la qualité des soins,
ils ont créé les CHU,
ça fait plus de 60 ans.
Est-ce que le CHU aujourd'hui est
toujours parfait ? Non. Le vrai
scandale, il est dans la désertification
certes, mais il est aussi dans le fait
qu'il y a des bons services et des
moyens services. L'évaluation des soins
n'est pas faite.
Deuxièmement,
vous avez la recherche médicale,
c'est la réforme 58. Tout professeur
doit faire de la recherche. Très bien.
Mais où est la stratégie aujourd'hui
dans le CHU de la recherche médicale et
universitaire ? Elle est où ? Qui décide
? Je vais vous dire où va l'argent moi
de l'université de la recherche dans un
CHU. C'est à peu près 15 20 %. Il va
dans le budget du trou noir de l'hôpital
parce que justement le directeur n'a pas
suffisamment d'argent pour faire marcher
son CHU. Donc résultat ça part à la
trappe. Donc personne il y a pas de
stratégie. Il y a pas de stratégie
puisquil y a pas il y a pas d'argent
pour la stratégie.
Troisièmement, l'enseignement qui fait
l'enseignement est-ce qu'il est évalué
l'enseignement.
Donc donc ça c'est la première médecine
médecine curative individuelle. Il y a
la deuxième dont je vous ai pas parlé
mais on va s'arrêter bientôt faire comm
mais c'est c'est la médecine préventive
et communautaire c'est-à-dire c'est la
médecine de demain. On va chifter on va
on va se déplacer de plus en plus de la
médecine curative et individuelle. vers
la médecine préventive et communautaire,
celle qui nous a manqué. Comment
protéger ce pays d'une épidémie, du
bioterrorisme ? Vous êtes intéressé euh
je crois euh par les affaires de de
politique étrangère. Donc le
bioterrorisme, c'est un sujet majeur qui
nous protège aujourd'hui. Imaginez que
on est un germe de la variole dans un
dans un château d'eau de l'Île-de-Fance.
Bon, que ça passe. Bon, c'est une
catastrophe. Comment on fait ? Qui est
organisé ? Comment on on laisse le
ministère de santé toujours organiser
les choses ? Non, il faut s'organiser.
Donc la médecine préventive et
communautaire, c'est fondamental. Euh
enfin, on pourrait dire plein de choses
encore.
Alors, on arrive à la fin de notre
interview et on a deux questions. C'est
c'est pas des questions, c'est
donnez-nous trois livres à lire et
laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Je dirais
le conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Les trois livres d'abord.
Je dirai
les mémoires du général de Gaul parce
que je trouve qu'elles sont
les fleurs du mal.
Et je vous laisse choisir par Miss Vig.
un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Euh
la tolérance,
le respect des autres mais au sens large
du terme.
Et plus ils sont pauvres, plus ils ont
des choses à dire. Et puis ils sont plus
ils sont soi-disant rien, plus ils ont
des choses à dire, plus ils sont aussi
importants que vous.
Et je pense que quand vous partez comme
ça dans la vie et quand vous avez ça en
dans la jeunesse, alors je pense que
vous il ne peut vous arriver que des
choses bien.
Philippe Doublasi, merci. C'est moi
[Musique]